ich rufe auf die einzelpläne 0 6 und 21
für das bundesministerium des innern und
für heimat das ist der einzelplan 06 mit
den beschlussempfehlungen
des haushaltsausschusses auf den
drucksachen
1606 und
1626 und bundesbeauftragter für den
datenschutz und die informationsfreiheit
das ist der einzelplan 21 mit den
beschlussempfehlungen des
haushaltsausschusses auf den drucksachen
1626 und
berichterstattung zu den beiden
einzelplänen haben die abgeordneten
janina schäfer martin gerster dr andré
berghegger dr thorsten lieb markus buhl
und victor perli
zu dem einzelplan 06 liegt je ein
änderungsantrag der fraktionen der
cdu/csu und der fraktion der afg vor für
die aussprache wurde eine dauer von 90
minuten vereinbart ich eröffne hiermit
die aussprache und als erster hat das
wort für die cdu csu fraktion dr andré
berghegger
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte ministerin feser im kolleginnen
und kollegen meine damen und herren wie
kann ein donnerstagmorgen in einer
haushaltswoche schöner beginnen als mit
der debatte des einzelplan 10 6 ich kann
mir etwas anderes vorstellen
intent
so hat stimmt das schon mal intensiven
haushaltsberatungen liegen hinter uns
und wir werden ende der woche einen
haushalt für das jahr 2022 beschließen
der ehrlicherweise nur ein halbes jahr
gültigkeit hat das müssen wir uns immer
wieder bewusst machen bis jetzt galt die
vorläufige haushaltsführung in diesem
zusammenhang dankt an das
innenministerium sehr geehrte frau
ministerin und an ihre mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter sie haben jederzeit
umfassend und zügig alle fragen
beantwortet das hat die arbeit sehr
erleichtert vielen dank an dieser stelle
erlauben sie mir einige grundlegende
anmerkungen zum haushalt im allgemeinen
bevor ich dann auf den einzelplan 06
eingehen werde ich zitiere mit erlaubnis
der präsidentin wir antworten auf die
ökonomische zeitenwende aufgrund der
inflation durch die rückkehr zu soliden
haushalten und das ende immer neue
schulden es war das der finanz ortes der
finanzminister lindner am dienstag in
der allgemeinen finanzdebatte gesagt
ehrlicherweise spekuliert der hier
leider nur über den haushalt 2 23 denn
der haushalt
2022 ist natürlich das komplette
gegenteil davon das kann man auch in den
zahlen nicht schönreden das weiß ja auch
nur er redet nicht zu behindern
das volumen dieses haushaltes beträgt
500 milliarden euro eine unvorstellbare
summe für die zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer an den bildschirm und
natürlich auch hier im saal davon werden
alleine rund 140 milliarden euro an
krediten aufgenommen 140 milliarden das
sind 140000 millionen nur noch mal
deutlicher zu machen auch eine
gigantische summe dazu werden wir das
sondervermögen der bundeswehr noch zu
zählen haben das allein bedeutet in
diesem jahr weitere 200 milliarden euro
an krediten wie irgendwann mit zins und
tilgung zurück zu zahlen sind und zu
bedienen warum sage ich dass der
finanzielle spielraum für die allgemeine
schuldenbremse in normalform beträgt
derzeit rund 23 milliarden euro und er
ist alleine durch die zurückzahlung der
korona sonderkredite aus dem letzten
jahr durch die durch die finanzielle
verpflichtung bei dem programm next
generation eu schon mit 15 bis 16
milliarden euro belegt das zeigt traurig
eine anmerkung zum nachdenken wie eng
der finanzielle spielraum und die
finanzpolitische verantwortung in den
nächsten jahren zu sehen ist
insbesondere wenn wir die schuldenbremse
einhalten wollen
liebe vertreterinnen der ampelkoalition
ich bin der festen überzeugung sie
können nicht einfach den
koalitionsvertrag abarbeiten und die
riesigen finanzpolitischen
herausforderungen aus der korona
pandemie und aus den auswirkungen des
ukraine krieges und ob setzen diese
rechnung wird schwer aufgehen sie werden
prioritäten setzen müssen die devise
wird sein pflicht vorführen wenn sie
sich auf das wesentliche konzentrieren
und wenn sie die schuldenbremse
einhalten vorsitz einhalten werden oder
es versuchen dann begrüßen wir das
natürlich natürlich werden wir aber
dabei auch andere thematische
schwerpunkte setzen wenn sie aber weiter
in den verschuldungsstaat gehen zu
lasten der nachfolgenden generation
werden wir wachsam sein und versuchen
sie auf den pfad der tugend
zurückzubringen die vergangenheit hat
doch gezeigt dass unter federführung
beginnend mit dem finanzminister
schäuble als besonderes beispiel hat
doch gezeigt wie wichtig finanzielle
polster sind um resilient zu sein und
handlungsfähig in schwierigen zeiten
darauf bis
zum einzelplan 06 im besonderen dazu
gibt es natürlich viel zu sagen von
ministerin mit ihren vielen
nachgeordneten behörden
selbstverständlich für die unions
fraktion kann ich glaube ich sagen dass
wir natürlich die stärkung der inneren
sicherheit im engeren sinne unterstützen
das steht außer frage sowohl den mittel
aufwuchs als auch den ställen auf und es
hier seien die 1000 zusätzlichen stellen
bei der bundespolizei besonders zu
erwähnen aber man muss auch deutlich
sagen es wäre mehr machbar gewesen bei
der inneren sicherheit es wäre mehr
machbar gewesen und das ohne
finanziellen mehraufwand im vergleich zu
jetzt sie verhalten sich aus meiner
sicht an zwei punkten widersprüchlich
und das möchte ich gerne verdeutlichen
nehmen auf der einen seite haben sie
eine art finanzpolitische
torschlusspanik und nehmen das geld was
wir bekommen können das erkennt man an
der neuen rücklage für unvorhergesehene
bedarf für unter anderem beim thw und
beim bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz
und katastrophenhilfe diese rücklage ist
den ergänzungs haushalt geschaffen
worden und hat die konkrete summe 34
millionen und 79.000 euro
zum gesamtbild zur vollständigkeit
gehört nur dazu sie parken hier schlicht
die rechts die restsumme der viertel
milliarde euro die der finanzminister
für das bmi vorgesehen hat ohne dass sie
hierzu aktuell einen bedarf haben
das finde ich ehrlicherweise nicht
seriös konsequent wäre aus ihrer sicht
gewesen wenn sie die mittel derzeit
nicht benötigen da sie keinen zweck der
derzeit dafür vorsehen dann nehmen sie
die mittel nicht in anspruch da würde
ein haushälter sagen das ist sparsame
und wirtschaftliche haushaltsführung
das haben sie leider nicht getan
aber die noch viel bessere lösung wäre
gewesen sie hätten einfach auch unseren
anträgen zu stärken des bbk auch in
diesen bereichen zustimmen können da
haben wir diverse vorschläge gemacht das
ist doch logisch wir haben die bereiche
zivile verteidigung bevölkerungsschutz
katastrophenhilfe das haben wir doch
aufstocken und haben das stärken wollen
das steht außer frage das haben wir
frühzeitig in vielen gesprächen deutlich
gemacht erfreulich ist dass die ampel im
laufe der haushaltsberatung die ein oder
andere idee aufgenommen hat und
entsprechende deckblätter formuliert hat
die konnten wir dann logischerweise
mittragen und wir konnten es ertragen
leider nur um mit schmerz dass sie
unsere deckblätter dann abgelehnt haben
aber das ging in die richtige richtung
so wirkt konstruktive opposition
auch auf der anderen seite bedenken sie
aber frau ministerin wir hatten doch den
missglückten beantragt 2020 die
flutkatastrophe im aartal und
schließlich spüren wir alle die
auswirkungen die schrecklichen aus der
ukraine situation aus dem krieg in der
ukraine es wird doch immer deutlicher
und wichtig wie wichtig entsprechende
informationen der bevölkerung
rechtzeitige warnungen und hinweise sind
wenn dann aber von dem erforderlichen
bedarf des bbk für die nina wann apple
für cell broadcast systeme für das
modulare warnsystem novas und bei der
unterstützung moderner sirenen ohne
dabei die länder aus der verantwortung
zu lassen das wird der kollege gerstner
sicherlich gleich wieder zurecht
ansprechen ohne die länder aus der
verantwortung zu lassen wenn aber von
dem angemeldeten bedarf nur rund die
hälfte bewilligt wird dann habe ich
fragen und der bedarf ist doch von den
fachleuten angemeldet worden hier hätten
sie die mittel aus der rücklage
einsetzen können ohne finanziellen
aufrufs hier wäre es sinnvoll angelegt
worden so ist das aus meiner sicht das
falsche signal
und da uns dieser punkt so wichtig ist
frau präsidentin hat es vorhin
angesprochen und da uns dieser punkt so
wichtig ist werden wir bis zum schluss
einen entsprechenden änderungsantrag
aufrechterhalten ich lege es nochmal den
abgeordneten kolleginnen und kollegen
der koalition noch mal darüber
nachzudenken sie haben noch anderthalb
stunden zeit wir wollen weiterhin eine
stärkung eine stärkung in diesem bereich
und deswegen stellen wir diesen
änderungsantrag zur abstimmung an die
fdp insbesondere appelliere ich
natürlich setzen sie sich weiter oder
vielleicht kann man auch sagen wieder
für eine seriöse haushalts und
fiskalpolitik ein und achten sie darauf
nächstes jahr die schuldenbremse wieder
einzuhalten vergessen sie nicht was sie
vor der wahl immer vehement kritisiert
haben unseriöse finanzen
schattenhaushalte hohe reste und der
gang in den schuldenstaat dieser
einzelplan hat noch luft hier wenig nur
die im vergleich zu anderen einzelplänen
zweitgrößten haushaltsreste die hier
vorliegen ist nur einer von mehreren
konsolidierungsbeiträge so sind sie
unglückliche signale setzen aus meiner
sicht falsche prioritäten und deswegen
werden wir den einzelplan ablegen
ablehnen und denken sie zum schluss
daran nicht nur hier sondern im gesamten
haushalt jede zeitenwende muss auch
nachhaltig finanziert werden ziehen sie
nächstes jahr wieder die schuldenbremse
das sind wir unseren kindern schuldig
vielen dank fürs freundliche zugang
andré berghegger war das aus der
unionsfraktion zu den zahlen zum geld
und damit auch zur grundlage für die
arbeit des bundesministerium des innern
und für heimat zu den politischen
vorhaben die damit umgesetzt werden
sollen jetzt die verantwortliche
ministerin nancy faeser
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren abgeordnete sehr
geehrte damen und herren zuschauerinnen
zuschauer wir haben seit mehreren
monaten nun leider schrecklichen krieg
angriffskrieg putins in der ukraine und
deswegen möchte ich zu beginn meiner
haushaltsrede denjenigen danken die im
moment großartiges leisten sei es die
helferinnen helfer des thw es die
hilfsleistungen in die ukraine selbst
fahren die vor ort unterwegs sind zu
unterstützen und die vielen tausend
flüchtlings helferinnen und helfer die
großartiges leisten bei der aufnahme der
ukrainischen geflüchteten herzlichen
dank dafür
neben dem furchtbaren krieg mitten in
europa kämpfen wir noch immer mit den
auswirkungen der korona pandemie immer
häufiger kommt es zu extremen
wetterereignissen die
lebenshaltungskosten und vor allen
dingen die energiekosten steigen das
alles beschäftigt die menschen in
deutschland sehr und viele machen sich
auch darüber sorgen sie machen sich
sorgen weil es hier nicht mit abstrakten
bedrohungen zu tun haben sondern diese
bedrohung wirken sich sehr konkret auf
ihren alltag aus sie sind sehr viel
spürbarer als in der vergangenheit und
es ist die zentrale aufgabe des staates
die menschen vor diesen bedrohungen zu
schützen meine damen und herren
für mich als ohne sehen ministerin hat
auch deshalb die sicherheit aller
menschen in unserem land oberste
priorität ganz gleich wie viel geld sie
haben wo ihre familien einmal herkamen
sicherheit ist aus meiner sicht eine
frage der sozialen gerechtigkeit und
angesichts der aktuellen krisen müssen
wir deutlich mehr für die sicherheit tun
wir haben in den letzten jahren viel
zeit mit innenpolitischen debatten
verschwendet die nicht besonders
zielführend waren dabei wurde oft mit
gefühlter sicherheit argumentiert mir
geht es um tatsächliche sicherheit
mit dem haushalt
2022 gehen die große schritte zu diesem
ziel er sieht für den einzelplan des
bundesinnenministeriums ein
gesamtvolumen von rund 15 milliarden
euro vor das ist ein plus von rund 8 189
millionen euro im vergleich zum entwurf
der vorgängerregierung und mit dem
ergänzungs haushalt kommen noch einmal
250 millionen euro für die folgen des
krieges in der ukraine hinzu dass es
gelungen ist so viele geflüchtete in so
kurzer zeit aufzunehmen zu schützen und
zu versorgen das ist eine großartige
leistung unseres gesamten landes meine
damen und herren
mit den zusätzlichen mitteln und neun
stellen stärken wir alle politikbereiche
des bundesinnenministeriums besonders
die kriminalitätsbekämpfung den
bevölkerungsschutz und die
cybersicherheit das bedeutet mehr
sicherheit für die menschen in der
bundesrepublik
konsequente kriminalitätsbekämpfung
heißt im umgang mit dem organisierten
verbrechen eine deutlich härtere gangart
einzulegen organisierte kriminalität ist
zwar oft weniger sichtbar als
terrorismus oder extremismus aber sie
ist genauso gefährlich das bka verstärkt
deshalb die bekämpfung von organisierter
kriminalität clan und rockerkriminalität
unter anderem mit konsequenten finanz
ermittlungen um illegales vermögen
schnell einzuziehen so können wir
kriminelle strukturen frühzeitig
erkennen und zu zerschlagen und das ist
auch zwingend gut wenn
meine damen und herren mir ist besonders
wichtig dass wir die verwundbarsten in
unserer gesellschaft besser schützen das
entsetzliche ausmaße sexuelle
sexualisierter gewalt gegen kinder macht
mir sehr große sorgen und fordert ein
konsequentes handeln wir brauchen den
höchstmöglichen ermittlungsdruck und die
täter und ihre netzwerke aufzudecken und
vor allen dingen die kinder zu schützen
dafür werden wir auch europäische
instrumente schaffen wir werden dabei
die private kommunikation der menschen
die mit diesen verbrechen überhaupt
nichts zu tun haben aber auch weiter
schützen mir geht es um ein sehr
gezieltes und sehr konsequentes vorgehen
gegen die täter und ihre netzwerke kein
täter darf sich sicher fühlen vor
strafverfolgung meine damen
ich bin deshalb auch froh dass wir für
die beiden behörden die vorrangigste
kriminalitätsbekämpfung zuständig sind
große stellen auf mixa erreichen konnten
das bundeskriminalamt der held 435 neue
stellen die bundespolizei das hat herr
dr berghegger schon gesagt über 1000
neue stellen das ist auch gut und
richtig und da darf ich mich bei der cdu
auch für die unterstützung an dieser
stelle bedanken meine damen und herren
wir erleben im moment eine vielzahl von
krisen und bedrohungen gleichzeitig das
bedeutet aber dass der
bevölkerungsschutz in deutschland auch
einen höheren stellenwert bekommen muss
hier ist es in vergangenen jahren und
jahrzehnten viel zu wenig passiert oder
sogar das gegenteil ich denke an den
abbau der sirenen im ganzen land mit dem
haushalt
2022 investieren wir deshalb erheblich
in bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe wir sorgen für moderne
warnsystem in ninas angesprochen worden
mit jeden die mit denen jeder präzise
warnungen direkt aufs handy bekommt wir
bauen neue logistikzentren für das thw
auf und wir verstärken die zivilschutz
reserve des bundes insbesondere mit
einem massiven aufwuchs auch durch den
ergänzungs haushalt im bereich des
projektes labor 5000 für diejenigen die
nicht wissen was es ist ein großes
infrastrukturprojekt was in jeder
krisenlage angewandt werden kann mit
zelten mit wasser abwasser system in
einer hausarztpraxis mit containersystem
sehr wichtig für alle formen der krise
und ich darf mich bei den
haushälterinnen haushälter der ampel
koalition sehr herzlich für die
unterstützung an dieser stelle bedanken
denn meine damen und herren im ernstfall
muss der staat handlungsfähig sein bei
kriegsbedingten gefahren bei
extremwetter ereignissen oder bei
stromausfällen auch unsere kritische
infrastruktur müssen im ernstfall
funktionieren unsere stadtwerke unsere
krankenhäuser unsere transportwege wir
sehen im moment darüber hinaus eine
große gefahr die insbesondere vom
angriff stick aus der ukraine kommt im
bereich der cyber angriffe auf genau
diese kritische infrastruktur deshalb
haben wir die schutzmaßnahmen massiv
hochgefahren
noch vor der sommerpause werde ich meine
cyber sicherheitsstrategie vorstellen
dazu gehört unter anderem dass wir den
bund die führende rolle in der cyber
sicherheit geben und das auch im
grundgesetz verankern dafür habe ich
bereits jetzt denn komplexe
cyberattacken kann nur der bund effektiv
etwas entgegensetzen wir haben mit dem
nationalen cyber abwehrzentrum sehr viel
expertise die wir mit diesem
vorliegenden haushalt noch weiter
ausbauen
in der bereinigungssitzung hat der
haushaltsausschuss aus meiner sicht noch
weitere wichtige akzente gesetzt
der ausschuss hat 25 millionen für ein
humanitäres aufnahmeprogramm für
besonders gefährdete menschen aus
afghanistan bereitgestellt auch für die
bekämpfung von antisemitismus wurden die
mittel noch einmal gehört erhöht ich
komme gerade aus israel und meine damen
und herren wir müssen unsere jüdischen
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger mehr
schützen in unserem land da haben wir
eine große verpflichtung
besonders aber freue ich mich dass der
ausschuss 25 millionen euro für das
programm neustart des sports nach corona
bereitgestellt hat die pandemie hat die
sportvereine sehr hart getroffen in der
bundesrepublik dass sie nun dabei
unterstützt werden endlich wieder
durchzustarten ist ein klares bekenntnis
auch zum breitensport in der
bundesrepublik deutschland und dafür
darf ich den haushälterinnen haushältern
der ampel koalition sehr herzlich danken
meine damen und herren dieser haushalt
ist gut für die menschen und für die
sicherheit derer die in deutschland
leben mehr schafft die basis dafür dass
das bundesinnenministerium für unsere
vorhaben rückenwind bekommt ich möchte
deshalb noch einmal ganz herzlich
bedanken bei den haushaltspolitischen
sprecherinnen und sprechern der
koalition denn es wurde sven christian
kindler und otto fricke sowie die für
den einzelplan des bmi zuständige
berichterstatterin der koalition janina
schäfer thorsten liebt und martin
gerster aber ich habe es gesagt ich
möchte mich auch bei herrn dr berker
gärten herrn pauli von der opposition
für die konstruktive beratung sehr
herzlich bedanken
meine damen und herren ein dank gilt
aber vor allen dingen den vielen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter meines
hauses die hervorragende arbeit in sehr
schwierigen zeiten leisten und mein
danke zum abschluss natürlich auch
finanzminister christian lindner für die
unterstützung all dieser vorhaben herzen
dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit danke für
die unterstützung der sicherheit der
menschen in unserem land
rechtsextremismus organisierte
kriminalität pädokriminalität der
bevölkerungsschutz das sind die
wichtigsten punkte gewesen in dem
beitrag vom bundesinnenministerium nancy
faeser aber natürlich auch der sport
denn das innenministerium ist
traditionell auch für den sport in
deutschland zuständige markus mühle ist
der nächste redner aus der fdp-fraktion
präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren die gewährleistung der inneren
sicherheit ist eine der wichtigsten
aufgaben eines status was wir allerdings
in 16 jahren merkel erlebt haben und
jetzt mit der links gelben regierung
erleben ist ein zunehmend
funktionsunfähige staat der immer
weniger in der lage ist seine
kernaufgaben wahrzunehmen der
vorliegende bundeshaushalt für
innenpolitik und heimat ist mit seiner
mittelverteilung ein erschreckendes
beispiel dafür links gelbe
prioritätensetzungen die bei den betrugs
anfälligen sprach und integrationskursen
glücklich mit deutschem steuergeld
ausgestattet während der grenzschutz
weiterhin völlig unzureichend ist und es
viel zu wenige neue
bundespolizisten gibt
bleiben wir gleich bei der bundespolizei
1000 zusätzliche stellen sind ein anfang
aber bevor diese verstärkung kommt
müssen drei jahre ausbildung durchlaufen
werden und jährlich geht vor allem in
den kommenden jahren ein beträchtlicher
teil der beamten in den ruhestand daher
gleicht die netto verstärkung
hauptsächlich die altersbedingten
abgänge aus von den neuen polizisten die
dieses jahr bei der bundespolizei fertig
ausgebildet sind wir hatten viele in den
ballungszentren mit hohen mieten
versetzt werden bieten die sich die
jungen polizei absolventen oft nicht
leisten können und wohngemeinschaften
bilden oder lange strecken pendeln
müssen wir haben daher einen antrag zur
einführung von orts zuschlägen in
großstädten für die jungen absolventen
gestellt kommen wir zum thema
einwanderung
2022 soll die mittel für integrations-
und sprachkurse
675 millionen euro umfassen durchgeführt
von circa
1.500 trägern die große sind zu einem
enormen geschäfts und
beschäftigungsmodell geworden vehement
verteidigt von den verfechtern der
politik der offenen grenzen schauen wir
auf die abrechnung bei diesen kursen und
fließt eigentlich nur dann geld an die
bildungsträger wenn die teilnehmer
anwesend sind und dies mit ihrer
unterschrift dokumentiert haben es
bedarf allerdings keine hellseher um zu
erkennen dass dieses konstrukt zum
betrug geradezu einlädt zum beispiel
unterschriften nachträglich zu leisten
oder zu beginnen und dann nicht am
unterricht halts in dem im jahr 2020
erreichen laut innenministerium 48
prozent der kursteilnehmer das
sprachniveau b1 nicht dass wir
allerdings notwendig für den
arbeitsmarkt die steigende zahl von
transferempfängern die deutsche sprache
nicht beherrschen bedeutet enorme lasten
für den sozialstaat also für den
deutschen steuerzahler
frau ministerin ich fordere fordern sie
dringend auf aufgrund dieser
erschreckenden ergebnisse wirksam zu
handeln ihre behörde das bundesamt für
migration und flüchtlinge hat hier
umfassende kontrollen
sanktionsinstrumente einzusetzen damit
die teilnehmerzahlen richtig abgerechnet
werden und wer danach war er
nachweislich keine bleibeperspektive in
deutschland hat braucht auch keinen
teuren integrationskurs
der bundesrechnungshof führt in seinem
bericht über die integrationsmaßnahmen
des bundes doppelförderung und die nicht
erreichung der gesteckten ziele an frau
ministerin nehmen sie diesen bericht
ernst eine weitere absurdität ist die
förderung der freiwilligen ausreise im
ergänzungs haushalt wird dieser zuschuss
um 20 millionen auf dann 59 millionen
euro erhöht es werden also personen die
zur ausreise rechtlich verpflichtet sind
mit prämien ausgestattet wenn sie sich
rechtskonform verhalten wie wenig
willens diese links gelbe
bundesregierung ist geltendes recht mit
den völlig normalen mitteln eines
rechtsstaates durchzusetzen zeigt dieses
beispiel sehr sehr eindrücklich
auch hier wird stattdessen steuergeld in
größenordnungen verschwendet wir werden
dem haushaltsplan daher nicht zustimmen
ich danke ihnen für ihre aufmerksamkeit
nächste rednerin für die fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen jamila schäfer und
familie schäfer ist mitglied im
haushaltsausschuss und auch
berichterstatterin ihrer fraktion zu
diesem feld
zurück zur sache bei diesen beratungen
zum bundeshaushalt mussten wir natürlich
den gestiegenen
sicherheitspolitischen anforderungen
schnell im laufenden verfahren gerecht
werden deshalb haben wir mit dem
ergänzungs haushalt von insgesamt über
26 milliarden euro und im
parlamentarischen verfahren
nachgesteuert und übernehmen
verantwortung für die sicherheit unserer
bevölkerung
der krieg in der ukraine
er hat natürlich gestiegene
verteidigungsausgaben notwendig gemacht
im ernstfall brauchen wir aber auch
einen funktionierenden zivilschutz
innerhalb deutschlands ganz egal ob es
um krieg geht oder um naturkatastrophen
kinderwagen systeme kosten menschenleben
das hat uns nicht zuletzt die
flutkatastrophe im aartal im letzten
jahr schmerzlich vor augen geführt
deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir uns
bundesweit für eine funktionierende
waren infrastruktur einsetzen und dass
dir das thw und das bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
jetzt nochmal mit jeweils 50 millionen
euro im ergebnishaushalt gestärkt haben
im parlamentarischen verfahren
haben wir dieses stärkeren jetzt auch
noch mal auf
33,5 millionen euro ausgebaut das
bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe kann jetzt zum
beispiel den ausbildungsstandort in
stralsund endlich in betrieb nehmen
entscheidungen katastrophenfällen zu
treffen braucht nämlich eine angemessene
schule und übungen der staat darf die
einsatzkräfte und entscheidungsträger
innen nicht allein lassen und dafür
werden wir gemeinsam sorgen
wir müssen natürlich aber auch die
erheblichen sicherheitslücken bei der
cyber security noch schließen menschen
leben stehen auf dem spiel wenn die
krankenhäuser oder unsere
wasserversorgung ohne schutz bleiben bei
der finanzierung haben wir hier noch
eine große aufgabe vor uns aber ich bin
mir sicher dass wir sie gemeinsam
meistern werden für die sicherheit und
weiterentwicklung unserer it stehen wir
stellen wir in diesem haushalt auch noch
einmal insgesamt 50 millionen euro zur
verfügung denn die zukunft heißt daten
souveränität und open source
zu einer verantwortungsvollen politik
gehört ist aber auch diejenigen zu
schützen die mit ihrer arbeit für unsere
sicherheit ihre eigene in gefahr
gebracht haben ja damit meine ich die
ortskräfte und die
menschenrechtsverteidigerinnen in
afghanistan nach 20 jahren
bundeswehreinsatz tragen wir weiterhin
eine große verantwortung für diejenigen
die hoffnungen uns gesetzt haben und
deren leben dort nun bedroht ist und
deshalb freue ich mich dass wir für die
aufnahme von besonders gefährdeten
menschen in afghanistan zusätzliche
gelder bereitstellen das ermöglicht
besonders gefährdete personen zu
evakuieren ist das bundes auf dem
programm aus dem koalitionsvertrag
endlich fertig aufgestellt ist am geld
wird die evakuierung jedenfalls nicht
scheitern dafür haben wir auch in diesem
bundeshaushalt gesorgt
nur eine vorausschauende
migrationspolitik gehört es natürlich
auch die migrationsberatung zu stärken
und zu entbürokratisieren
hier hat leider die letzte
bundesregierung oft erst nachgesteuert
wenn es schon zu spät war die ampel
macht es umgekehrt wir lassen diejenigen
die tagtäglich dafür sorgen dass
geflüchtete hier gut ankommen können
nicht im stich die ampel macht eine
zeitgemäße innenpolitik das haben wir im
haushaltsausschuss mit unseren anträgen
in höhe von insgesamt 155 millionen euro
auch noch einmal unterstrichen ich
bedanke mich ganz herzlich bei meinen
mit berichterstattern ganz insbesondere
noch mal bei martin gerster und thorsten
gibt aber natürlich auch der
innenministerin fraser und ihrem haus
für die konstruktive beratungen wir
werden diesem einzelplan
selbstverständlich zustimmen vielen dank
jamila schäfer für die fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen in der debatte des
bundestags über den einzelplan im 06 der
verbunden diskutiert wird mit dem
einzelplan 21 das ist der für den
datenschutzbeauftragten und in dieser
debatte jetzt martina renner aus der
linksfraktion sprecherin für
innenpolitik
hat die koalition nun ein
aufnahmeprogramm für das land vereinbart
das begrüßen wir ganz deutlich hierfür
sind aber lediglich 25 millionen euro
eingestellt das reicht nach eigenen
berechnungen des innenministeriums
gerade mal für die aufnahme von 5000
menschen wir sprechen also von 1000
gefährdeten personen und ihren engsten
familienangehörigen
nach meinung von menschenrechts
organisationen müssen aber mehrere
zehntausende schutzsuchende so schnell
wie möglich vor den taliban in
sicherheit gebracht werden wir sagen es
darf kein aufnahmeprogramm nach
kassenlage geben
meine damen und herren im haushalt sind
erneut mehr stellen für die
sicherheitsbehörden vorgesehen das
bundeskriminalamt kann so finde ich auch
gerne fachlich geeignete mitarbeiter und
mitarbeiterinnen einstellen die sich zum
beispiel um hass kriminalität im
internet kümmerten oder personal für die
notwendige strafverfolgung von in der
ukraine begangenen kriegsverbrechen das
ist richtig aber zuerst muss auf die
frage geantwortet werden warum es so
lange dauerte die noch offenen stellen
zu besetzen
hier muss gehandelt werden ich finde
dann sollte man über das geld reden
zur bundespolizei
die bundespolizei verdoppelte die zahl
der anlasslosen kontrollen im letzten
jahr verdoppelte das muss man sich
vorstellen aber zeitgleich fehlt das
personal zum beispiel bei der
verhinderung und verfolgung von
angriffen von neonazis auf züge in
sachsen am ersten mai es ist so glaube
ich keine frage des budgets sondern der
prioritätensetzung halten wir fest
mehr beamtinnen und beamten schaffen
nicht automatisch mehr sicherheit
mit klick auf den haushalt stellen sich
mir noch weitere frage was ist
eigentlich mit den fehlenden polizei
beauftragten für die polizeibehörden des
bundes was geschieden mit der
überwachungs gesamtrechnung das
prestige-objekt scheint ja zwischen den
ministerien zerredet zu werden um
zuletzt mich hat die tage die aussage
meiner kollegin linda teuteberg in einem
interview zum demokratie fortgesetzt
wirklich irritiert es sieht danach aus
als müssten die zivilgesellschaftlichen
projekte erneuten nach der letzten
legislatur sorge haben dass dieses
gesetzesvorhaben nicht umgesetzt wird
der kampf gegen neonazis rassismus und
antisemitismus ist aber staatsaufgabe
und die zivilgesellschaft muss dauerhaft
gefördert werden vielen dank
nächster redner für die fdp fraktion dr
thorsten liebt
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin verehrte
kolleginnen und kolleginnen die bevor
ministerin feser herr kollege da krieg
ich kann sie beruhigen um den
haushaltspolitischen kompass der fdp
fraktion müssen sich gar keine sorgen
machen sie werden sind drei wochen sehen
bei der vorlage des haushalts für 2023
keine angst und weil sie das thema des
bevölkerungsschutzes und es der
katastrophenhilfe angesprochen haben nur
einen hinweis von meiner seite wir
setzen das jetzt in der koalition um was
sie im vergangenen jahr nur angekündigt
haben deswegen brauchen wir hier keine
belehrung und kolleginnen kollegen
die hier heute vorliegende fassung des
einzelplan sex zeigt wie die koalition
in zeiten von krisen handlungsfähigkeit
beweis und schwerpunkte setzt es ist in
den haushaltsberatungen einzelner noch
mal gelungen gerade in bereichen
digitalisierung bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe noch einmal deutlich
nach zu schaffen besonders hervorheben
möchte ich in dem bereich aber auch die
umfassenden maßnahmen zur stärkung von
cyber sicherheit und resilienz und zur
beschleunigung von wald verwaltungs
digitalisierung zwar dringend nötig dort
weiterzumachen beispielsweise mit dem
aufbau des zentrums für digitale
souveränität der öffentlichen verwaltung
gelingt endlich ein erheblicher sprung
zu mehr digitaler souveränität in diesem
land mit zusätzlichen 37,5 und insgesamt
über 50 millionen euro investieren wir
da massiv in die zukunft dieses landes
der souveräne arbeitsplatz das
wesentliche kern kernprojekt in diesem
bereich setzt auf open source und
leistet damit einen beitrag zu echter
nationaler souveränität in dem bereich
und es macht es durch das offene modell
durch den offenen ansatz auch
transparent und sorgt damit gleichzeitig
auch noch für eine erhöhte sicherheit
der systeme damit wird ein ganz
wichtiges vorhaben des
koalitionsvertrages gleich im ersten
haushalts umgesetzt
die potenziale von daten endlich
umfassend zu heben und dazu ein echtes
daten gesetz für rechtssicherheit bei
der datennutzung zu schaffen dass es uns
als koalition ein zentrales anliegen und
dazu braucht es klar viel mehr als einen
bloßen quantensprung damit deutschland
endlich in die weltspitze der daten
ökonomie vor stehst das ist nicht neu
land liebe kollegin kollegen das
zukunftsland und sehen wir zu dass wir
endlich in der zukunft ankommen es wird
allerhöchste zeit
wir leiten in strukturellen umbau der
sicherheitsarchitektur ein und machen
das bundesamt für sicherheit
informationstechnik endlich unabhängig
damit kommen wir einen weiteren schritt
vorwärts beim aufbau des bsi als
zentrale stelle im bereich der
it-sicherheit
dazu schutz digitale infrastrukturen ist
eine der zentralen
sicherheitspolitischen herausforderungen
unserer zeit auch deswegen habe einen
erheblichen schritt noch mal nach vorne
gemacht im rahmen der haushaltsberatung
wir können cyber sicherheit stärken bei
kritischen infrastrukturen beim thw ist
das gelungen bei den maltesern der die
notwendigkeit von cyber sicherheit geht
natürlich weit über den karren der
inneren sicherheit hinaus da haben wir
geliefert über kolleginnen kollegen
ein paar abschließende worte zum sport
ministerin hat es angesprochen während
der korona zeit ist schulunterricht
ausgefallen angebote von sportvereinen
wurden wurden eingestellt deswegen ist
wichtig dass wir dieses programm
auflegen ich sage das bewusst aus
aktuellem anlass wenn ich die vielen
schülerinnen und schüler je im saal sehe
vor zwei tagen kam eine studie die
deutlich gemacht hat es ist viel weniger
bewegung passiert im panini zeiten des
weges ist ein ganz zentrales signal für
den sport für den breitensport und auch
für die gesundheit dort nach vorne zu
kommen sport braucht aber auch vorbilder
deswegen ist uns auch die förderung des
spitzensport ist ein zentrales anliegen
mehr athleten können bei internationalen
wettbewerben teilnehmen das haben wir
erreicht wir unterstützen zusätzlich die
special olympics world ging es hier in
berlin und das bekannte institut eine
unserer medaillen stehen das fes hier in
berlin können wir mit zusätzlichen
mitteln versorgen eine echte deutsche
erfolgsgeschichte sorgen wir dafür dass
es so bleibt wir haben jedenfalls vor
als koalition auch die innenpolitik zu
einer echten erfolgsgeschichte zu machen
dafür stehen wir vielen dank
kosten lieber das haus in der
fdp-fraktion nebenbei stellvertretender
nicht nebenbei aber auch wichtig zu
sagen stellvertretender vorsitzender im
rechtsausschuss des bundestages nächster
redner jetzt in dieser debatte zum etat
des bundesinnenministeriums
alexander throm der innenpolitische
sprecher der unions fraktion
die kolleginnen und kollegen
wir leben in einer krisengeschüttelten
zeit mit großen herausforderungen eine
zeit in der sich unsere bürgerinnen und
bürger vor allem die nach klaren
verlässlichen kurs ihrer regierung
sehnen aber fehlanzeige
das was wir bislang von ihnen gehört
haben waren viele teils widersprüchliche
frau ministerin ankündigungen aber
keinerlei umsetzung und das schafft
weder eine gefühlte sicherheit und noch
weniger eine tatsächliche sich
wenn dazu
wäre es notwendig dass sie erst mal ihr
haus bestellen viele positionen haben
sie geräumt das ist in ordnung nach
einem regierungswechsel auch die des
beamteten staatssekretärs für migration
diese position ist seit sechs monaten
unbesetzt dagegen haben sie sich gleich
drei beamtete staatssekretäre gegönnt in
einer antwort von dieser woche auf eine
abgeordnete abfrage von mir weshalb es
denn mehr staatssekretäre brauche haben
sie gesagt die zahl der staatssekretäre
spiegele das sehr große aufgaben
portfolio aufgrund der zentralen
vorhaben der neuen bundesregierung
wieder frau ministerin das passt nicht
der zuständigkeitsbereich des
innenministeriums ist geschrumpft
nicht gestiegen das einzige was ich mir
erklären kann ist dass diese drei
staatssekretäre ihnen den rücken frei
halten sollen damit sie den wahlkampf in
hessen bestreiten können aber
frau ministerin
das innenministerium ist keine
wahlkampfzentrale und es ist in der tat
zu wichtig als dass es eine freizeit
ministerin auf ab und zu fragen
denn wir müssen beispielsweise
den kampf gegen den kindesmissbrauch
noch energischer führen und das nicht
erst seit dem bekanntwerden der
widerwärtigen taten in nrw diese woche
und da haben sie zunächst frau
ministerin die vorschläge der
eu-kommission zur zeitkontrolle begrüßt
nach kritik von fdp und grünen sind sie
zurück gerudert was es aber tatsächlich
braucht das sind gesetzliche
mindestspeicherfristen von mindestens
sechs monaten und ja es braucht den
zugriff auf die ip-adressen
justizminister busemann will uns
weismachen dass das sogenannte
quick-freeze-verfahren
ausreicht es ist keine alternativen bei
die verbindungsdaten sind bereits
gelöscht wenn sie den zugriff machen
wollen das heißt die täter entkommen und
noch schlimmer wir können die opfer
nicht schützen deswegen begrüße ich
außerordentlich dass sie gestern
erstmals zu erkennen gegeben haben dass
sie auch auf die ip adressen zugreifen
wollen war abend haben sie das heute
morgen in ihrer regel nicht nochmals
wiederholt ich will es ihnen sagen weil
ich in diesem punkt keine zustimmung
kein applaus von fdp und grünen der
komplett deswegen hoffe ich sehr dass
sie auch in diesem punkt nicht wieder
zurückrudern müssen weil wir müssen hier
einen besseren schutz und bessere
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten bei diesem
widerwärtigen taten von kindesmissbrauch
abschaffen
und liebe kollegen kollegen jetzt schon
gesagt worden da müssen natürlich auch
bei der cyber sicherheit besser werden
das nicht erst seit dem 24
danach ist es umso dringender aber auch
hier widersprüchliches von ihnen erst
haben sie im kampf gegen cyberattacken
die möglichkeit sogenannte hacks ins
spiel gebracht nach kritik von fdp und
grünen haben sie auch dies wieder
relativiert und gemerkt dass im
koalitionsvertrag entsprechende heck
becks ausgeschlossen sind was gilt denn
nun und auch jetzt diese woche wiederum
haben sie vorgeschlagen dass man hier
mehr cyber sicherheit machen müsste der
krieg dauert seit 100 tagen was haben
sie hier konkret getan jedenfalls in den
haushaltsansätzen in diesem
haushaltsansatz auch im ergänzungs
haushalt findet sich hierzu nichts neues
und auch die bevölkerungsschutz hat sich
für unruhe gesorgt erst haben sie die
bevölkerung aufgefordert notvorräte zu
beschaffen anzunehmen keine zwei wochen
später haben sie die vorschläge und
empfehlungen ihres eigenen amtes sogar
das großen schutz in frage gestellt das
sorgt für verunsicherung und nicht für
tatsächliche sicherheit vermissen
ja wir brauchen mehr geld wird den
katastrophen und zivilschutz aber wo
bleibt da ein kräftiger vorschlag aus
ihrem haus für diesen haushalt auch
nicht im ergänzungs haushalt 77
millionen euro wir haben nicht erwartet
dass sie gleich die zehn milliarden auf
einmal in den haushalt einstellen aber
0,77 prozent dessen was erforderlich ist
ist eindeutig zu wenig
und sie herr kollege kritisch waren da
die längste zeit mit dabei
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
und auch in der migrationspolitik können
wir leider nur ein irrlichtern
feststellen erst die ankündigung einer
koalition der willigen unter deutscher
führung dann kritik diesmal nicht mit
den fdp und grünen sondern aus der
gesellschaft und in den medien dann ein
zurückrudern das sei ja gar kein eigener
vorschlag sondern man würde sich nur der
initiative des französischen präsidenten
anschließend dann bei dem thema sekundär
migration völlige untätigkeit etwa
43.000 menschen die in griechenland
bereits anerkannt sind als
schutzberechtigte kommen nach
deutschland beantragen hier erneut asyl
ich an sechs monaten keine einzige
äußerung noch wenige tag weniger taten
in diesem thema festgestellt laut
koalitionsvertrag soll es eine
rückführung offensive geben sechs monate
nichts passiert arbeitsverweigerung noch
nicht bei den bevollmächtigten für
migrations abkommen bekommen sehen weil
sie sich wieder frau berg streiten wenn
dieser allerdings nicht bei ihnen im
ministerium angesiedelt ist dann
offenbart sich die rückführung offensive
als das hat sie es nämlich eine
luftnummer herzlichen dank
alexander throm war das der
innenpolitische sprecher der
unions-fraktion naturgemäß möchte man
fast sagen nicht einverstanden mit
vielen punkten die die bundesebene
ministerin hier vor einigen minuten
vorgetragen hat zu ihrem etat und zu
ihren politischen vorhaben eben diesem
jahr der nächste redner ist martin
gerster spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin wirte
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
frau ministerin nancy faeser
gegensatz zur darstellung des kollegen
throm will ich sagen die wehrhaftigkeit
der demokratie die widerstandsfähigkeit
unserer gesellschaft im inneren wird mit
diesem haushalt gestärkt und zwar
spürbar nachhaltig und ganz im sinne der
zeitenwende in dem wir prävention
politische bildung den schutz unserer
bevölkerung und den zusammenhalt unserer
gesellschaft in den mittelpunkt der
politik rücken das ist die wahrheit und
das sondervermögen war dass wir auch in
diesen wochen diskutieren war notwendig
und ist notwendig für die äußere
sicherheit für die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung
im einzelplan 06 wird die zeit wenn die
im inneren unseres landes deutlich
sichtbar einige beispiele 1000 stellen
für die bundespolizei waren bereits im
regierungsentwurf von nancy faeser drin
jetzt ermöglichen wir der bundespolizei
in den kommenden jahren weitere 2000
planstellen aus zu bringen so dass wir
schon in diesem jahr die anwärterinnen
und anwärter dafür einstellen können das
bundeskriminalamt erhält 107 stellen
mehr außerdem zehn millionen euro aus
dem ergänzungs haushalt für polizeiliche
ausbildungen ausstattungshilfe in der
ukraine auch dass es zeit und wände das
bka genießt international eine hohe
reputation in der forensik zur
untersuchung und beweisaufnahme von
kriegsverbrechen hier unterstützen wir
die ukraine damit gräueltaten an
zivilisten und zivilisten aufgeklärt und
täter zur verantwortung gezogen werden
können ich glaube das ist auch richtig
und notwendig
es zeigt bei nancy faeser und bei uns in
der ampel ist sicherheit in guten händen
und das gilt auch für bevölkerungs und
katastrophenschutz sowie zivilschutz der
ergänzungs haushalt allein sieht
investitionen von über 50 millionen euro
vor und da kann man sich über den
änderungsantrag der union ehrlich gesagt
nur wundern denn hier wird heute ja
beantragt dass wir für die
nachrichten-app nina und wahn systeme
wie über cell broadcast 19 millionen
euro zusätzlich zur verfügung stellen
sollen entschuldigung das ist im
ergänzungs haushalt schon drin das ist
schon beschlossen wir haben nämlich 420
millionen euro für eine moderne waren
infrastruktur einem weiter entwickelten
katastrophenschutz waren sap system mit
sms mahnung und einer digitalen
schnittstelle drin mit verweis auf die
entsprechenden haushaltstitel der antrag
liebe an triberg ist also obsolet also
das papier bitte schön schnell wieder
einrollen sonst wird es nämlich ganz
schön peinlich an dieser stelle
beim technischen hilfswerk gibt es
unglaublich gute resonanz auf die
beschlüsse von uns in der
bereinigungssitzung
aufgrund unserer anträge die wir als
ampel
vorgebracht haben es gibt zwei so
zusätzliche logistik zentren zur
krisenvorsorge zehn millionen euro zur
anschaffung von sogenannten mmogs hoch
geländegängigen fahrzeugen eine halbe
million euro für die cyber hilfe die
durch das thw in zukunft geleistet
werden soll und im übrigen ganz
besonders die positive resonanz über
unser liegenschafts programm wir haben
99 millionen euro zusätzlich anbieten
bei der bima organisiert damit 30 bis 50
zusätzliche thw unterkünfte modernisiert
werden können gute rahmenbedingungen für
unsere ehrenamtlichen im thw und darüber
hinaus das ist es was die ehrenamtlichen
brauchen und drückt auch unsere
dankbarkeit aus für das was sie rund um
die uhr in den einsätzen in deutschland
und international leisten
auch im bereich der migration und
integration steht viel mehr geld zur
verfügung das muss man ganz klar sagen
ich verweise auf
zusätzliche gelder 8 millionen euro für
die integration für die
migrationsberatung für erwachsene
zuwanderer ich freue mich auch dass mit
fünf millionen euro jetzt erste
vorbereitungen für die unabhängige
asylverfahrens beratung getroffen werden
können ein zentrales anliegen von uns in
der ampel und von uns in der spd mit dem
letzten innenminister und mit cdu/csu
wäre dies wahrscheinlich niemals möglich
gewesen das zeigt zeitenwende auch in
anderen politikbereichen und darauf
glaube ich können wir auch ganz schön
stolz einer als ampel dass wir das jetzt
auf den weg bringen
wir haben bei der bundeszentrale für
politische bildung jetzt dann die marke
100 millionen euro im etat erreicht das
ist absoluter rekord und zeigt dass wir
auch politische bildung setzen dass wir
auf prävention setzen das gilt im
übrigen auch was das thema
antisemitismus anbelangt das ist ja
erschreckend welche entwicklung das
ganze nimmt und es ist gut dass wir hier
zeichen setzen mittel aufwuchs und mehr
stelle damit bei antisemitismus besser
bekämpfen können im übrigen auch sehr
gut wir stärken den sport dazu wird
sabine poschmann für die spd fraktion
noch mal was sagen jedenfalls bin ich
der meinung wir sind gut aufgestellt im
etat des bundesinnenministeriums
möchte mich bedanken bei famila schäfer
und bei torsten lieb insbesondere aber
natürlich auch bei der ministerin nancy
faeser und ihrem ganzen haus für die
hervorragende zusammenarbeit das war
wirklich klasse gute grundlage für die
nächsten jahre in dieser legislatur oder
was denn in etwa anbelangt herzlichen
dank
martin gerster für die spd-fraktion und
vielleicht auch noch ein paar zahlen zu
dem was er zuletzt gesagt hat 20 21 gab
es so viele politisch motivierte
straftaten wie noch nie mehr als 55.000
auch die judenfeindlichen straftaten
haben zugenommen einen höchststand 29
prozent mehr als 20 20 jetzt gottfried
curio der innenpolitischen sprecher der
fdp-fraktion eine zeitenwende im
innenressort bleibt aus es bleibt alles
beim alten grenzen offen portemonnaie
offen germany last and least migration
hunderttausende durch 60 länder gezogen
werden uns an der grenze als fliegende
aufgenötigt und die fdp will von ihrem
abschiebe beauftragten koalitionsvertrag
schon nichts mehr wissen man hat ja
einen queer beauftragten zur
kriminalität 20 21 ein drittel der
tatverdächtigen ausländer in münchen
stuttgart düsseldorf geht die hälfte
aller straftaten auf ihr konto in
frankfurt zwei drittel die lösung der
ampelmann bürger noch schneller ein und
schon gibt es weniger kriminelle
ausländer die bürger lassen sich aber
nicht für dumm verkaufen frau feser
auf sonst wird die sicherheit
vorsätzlich vernachlässigt von links gab
es letztes jahr mehr politische
gewalttaten als von rechts dramatisch
viel mehr gegen polizeibeamte
islamistische gefährder achtmal mehr als
rechtsextreme islamistische terror
verfahren 40 mal mehr als antwort man
erfindet eine schlagzeile
rechtsextremismus in sicherheitsbehörden
bei anhaltspunkten bei 300 personen von
600.000 ein halbes prozent 90 95 prozent
waren klien die schlagzeile bewusste
desinformation und wo sind ihre ansätze
gegen kleinkriminalität nancy faeser hat
die prioritäten erkannt sie zeigt flagge
vom ministerium die
regenbogenflagge und eine milliarde für
linke lobbygruppen migrantenvereine zur
angeblichen demokratie förderung
natürlich mit projekt autonomie aber
ohne bekenntnis zur fdp das braucht
niemand meine damen und herren
aber fässer will nicht nur rechtsextreme
netzwerke zerschlagen gehen jeder
innenausschusssitzung verzweifelt
gesucht werden aber nie auftauchen
wollen schon im kindergarten brauche es
demokratieerziehung dass es egal ist wo
eine familie mal hergekommen ist es geht
überhaupt nicht um extremismusbekämpfung
es geht um indoktrination kritik an der
aggressiven zuwanderungspolitik soll
abzug werden das ziel keine mündigen
bürger sondern links programmierte
schlaf schafe das ist nicht die madrid
förderung sondern behinderung aber damit
kennen sie sich ja aus meinungs-
unterdrückung durch ihr netz
zensurgesetz
oppositions unterdrückung hier im haus
durch verwirrung der minderheitenrechte
wer hier das demokratie problem ist das
sind sie
und die ministerin will für ihren
politischen begriff
kampfbegriffe umfeld schon etwa das wort
heimat positiv umdeuten heimat ist für
sie ein negativer begriff o ton es ist
ein offener begriff dass alle menschen
so leben können wie sie möchten man will
also nicht integration einfordern
sondern enthaltung der einheimischen
feser der begriff soll signalisieren
dass wir die gesellschaft zusammenhalten
wollen nein das soll oder nicht er
bedeutet viel mehr den anspruch der
einheimischen bevölkerung auf ein leben
in ihrem land nach gewachsenen
traditionen die menschen um ihre heimat
zu betrügen das wird ihnen nicht gelegen
und der rechtsbruch geht weiter man
belässt migranten nicht in erst ankunft
ländern gibt hunderttausende abgelehnte
nicht abkoppelt entwicklungshilfe nicht
an rücknahme illegaler migranten dafür
darf der steuerzahler seit 2005 10 900
tausend migranten in hartz4 beköstigen
es bräuchte sach statt geldleistungen
für asylbewerber effektiver
abschiebungen mehr sichere
herkunftsländer stattdessen fordert
spd-frau frattini und die grünen noch
mehr anreize für einwanderung in die
sozialsysteme hartz4 sofort für jeden
über die grenzen kommt das wird unsere
ärmeren mitbürger jetzt sicher freuen so
viele wohltaten und 9 milliarden zu
angeblichen flucht ursachenbekämpfung
eine absurde riesen gießkanne ins
ausland das wird unsere inflations
geplagten bürger freuen und jetzt noch
milliarden für die ukraine wer wollte da
noch niedrigere heizkreise wenn ihnen so
das herz gewärmt wird immer getreu dem
regierungs motto wir kümmern uns um
jeden solange er nicht aus deutschland
stammt ich danke ihnen
herr choreo aus der fdp fraktion hält an
seinem thema fest jetzt geht es weiter
in der debatte um den ihnen etat mit
marcel emmerich aus der fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen obmann im ausschuss für
inneres und heimat
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen zunächst mal zu
meinem vorredner ich bin neu im
deutschen bundestag und das eine sehr
sehr große ehre hier in diesem redepult
zu stehen und diesen wohnhaus zu reden
und das ist wirklich fürchterlich wie
sie mit diesem redepult umgehen welche
ständigen tierarten die hier raus machen
und wie
diese ehre hier zu hause immer wieder
hergestellt
hinter uns liegen ganz besondere
haushaltsverhandlungen mit wirklich eine
hoch mit hochmotivierten
regierungsfraktionen mit einer neuen
engagierten minister ministerin und
gleichzeitig aber auch schwierigen und
dynamischen umständen eine pandemie
einem angriffskrieg in europa und einer
fluchtbewegung die uns vor
herausforderungen gestellt das sind die
manager aufgaben für den bund für die
länder die kommunen für die vielen
ehrenamtlichen und auch die
sicherheitskräfte und insbesondere
beiden letzteren gilt unsere
unterstützung und unser dank für ihre
tolle arbeit herzlichen dank
und ja sie sind ein haushaltsdebatte da
geht es um geld aber geld allein macht
nicht glücklich aber es ist dennoch
immer eine gute grundlage um seine
politischen anliegen voranzubringen und
in diesem fall für eine politik die wert
darauf legt freiheit sicherheit und
rechtsstaatlichkeit für alle menschen zu
gewährleisten
mit einem klaren bekenntnis zur
humanitären aufnahme von geflüchteten
der stärkung der demokratie
für einen funktionsfähigen zivil und
katastrophenschutz und herd rom mit
einem evidenzbasierten und grundrechts
orientierten ansatz der auch
rechtssicher so machen wir das bei
fragen und überwachung das ist im
kernbereich
nicht erschüttert und dass es kein
generalverdacht gibt dass das unser
anliegen und sie sind da ganz falsch
unterwegs
deswegen stoßen wir im haushalt auch zum
beispiel jetzt die überwachungs
gesamtrechnung an und gelegen dass mit
geld wir stärken das bbk und das thw
unter anderem mit geländegängigen
fahrzeugen oder auch unimog genannt wir
sorgen auch für mehr geld für die
unterbringung der geflüchteten und
setzten den starken fokus auf die
it-sicherheit
in den letzten wochen und monaten haben
wir aber auch noch was anderes wieder
sehr deutlich zu spüren bekommen auf sie
eingehen möchte
razzien um die zellen der sogenannten
atomwaffen division kombat eighteen und
knock out fiktiven auseinanderzunehmen
razzien in 20 objekten den neuen
bundesländern um die so genannten seiten
patrioten auszuhebeln sie zählten unter
anderem mit anschlägen auf den
gesundheitsminister ab hatten pistolen
kalaschnikow 80 geräte und vieles mehr
und standen bereit und jeremy er plante
einen rechtsextremistisch motivierten
anschlag auf schülerinnen und lehrkräfte
in dem von ihm besuchten gymnasium in
essen wir sehen die bedrohung
rechtsextremer
gewalt bleibt hochaktuell und an diesen
nachrichten die wir in den letzten
wochen genannt bekommen haben dürfen wir
uns nicht gewöhnen wir dürfen das nicht
hinnehmen wir stellen uns diesen
gedanken
wir stellen uns recht in netzwerken
entschieden entgegen
und an dieser stelle möchte ich auch den
ermittlungsteams danken die das aus
ermittelt und aufgedeckt haben das
verdeutlicht ein entschlossenes vorgehen
der sicherheitsbehörden ist von
besonderer bedeutung und deswegen
starten wir diese jetzt auch weiter
personell gut aus und außerdem stärken
die zivilgesellschaft die auch im kampf
gegen rechts so wichtig ist rechter
terror ist die bedrohung für unsere
demokratie der einsatz dagegen hat
oberste priorität für uns das will ich
mit blick auch auf den lästigen dritten
todestag von walter lück mir noch mal
dick und fett unterstreichen
sehr geehrte frau ministerin sie haben
einen aktionsplan gegen
rechtsextremismus vorgelegt wir sind
bereit ihn abzuarbeiten gemeinsam
hoffentlich auch mit allen
demokratischen fraktionen hier im haus
wir sind dazu bereit wir wollen loslegen
fangen wir an und diese einzelfragen ist
eine gute basis dafür vielen dank
marcel emmerich für die fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen obmann im innenausschuss
des bundestages ihm wird jetzt folgen
andré hahn aus der linkspartei unter
anderem sprecher für den themenbereich
sport aber auch für die geheimdienst
kontrolle und für zivilen
katastrophenschutz und der
katastrophenschutz spielt ja eine
deutlich größere rolle als in früheren
jahren in diesem haushalt als sprecher
der fraktion die linke für zivil- und
katastrophenschutz möchte ich dazu
einige anmerkungen machen die
aufstockungen für das technische
hilfswerk begrüßen wir ausdrücklich das
darf aber nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen
zügig hinzu dass unser land im fall von
naturkatastrophen pandemien und größeren
flugbewegungen nach wie vor schlecht
aufgestellt ist stadt zusätzliche 100
milliarden für die bundeswehr zu
verpulvern wäre es gut wenn wenigstens
ein bruchteil dieser mittel für den
zivilen katastrophenschutz zur verfügung
gestellt würde und ihn selbst bayerns
innenminister herrmann fordert dafür
zehn milliarden euro kam es im
innenministerium auch beim
katastrophenschutz modul labor 5000 wie
viele gute module sollen denn nun
wirklich neu angeschafft und dauerhaft
finanziert werden keine klaren aussagen
nun zum sport am 27 april war ministerin
feser im sportausschuss auf meine frage
ob es nach ihrem amtsantritt personelle
veränderungen der abteilung sport
gegeben hat oder ob solche vorgesehen
sind haben sie frau ministerin
geantwortet zitat mit der abteilung bin
ich sehr zufrieden ich habe nicht vor
sie zu verändern letzte woche wurden
plötzlich die abteilungsleiterin in den
vorzeitigen ruhestand versetzt laut
medienberichten angeblich wegen
unüberbrückbarer differenzen dazu heute
kein wort von ihnen bei sportstätten und
schwimmbädern gibt es nach wie vor einen
bundesweiten sanierungsstau von mehr als
30 milliarden euro die koalition hat
jetzt dafür lediglich 449 millionen euro
bereitgestellt verteilt auf sechs jahre
das ist nicht mehr als der tropfen auf
den heißen stein wir als linke fordern
einen echten goldenen plan sportstätten
an dem sich der bund in den kommenden
zehn jahren mit jeweils einer milliarde
euro beteiligt und diese position teilen
inzwischen auch der dfb und der deutsche
städtetag
letzter gedanke ich hoffe dass wir uns
alle einig sind dass der sport eine
herausragende bedeutung in unserer
gesellschaft hat deshalb frage ich wo
bleibt der überfällige sport und
bewegung bewegungs gipfel im kanzleramt
den nicht nur der dfb fordert herr
bundeskanzler laden sie endlich dazu ein
der fc bundestag hat im nacht lieber
seine musik und
parlamentarier turnier geliefert das
innenministerium muss beim haushalt noch
deutlich nachlegen
nächster redner für die fdp-fraktion
platin coole modells stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender
frau präsidentin
meine damen und herren heute vor drei
jahren wurde der kasseler
regierungspräsident weiter lücke von
einem rechtsextremisten erschossen und
der kollege emmerich hat gerade daran
erinnert und zu recht darauf aufmerksam
gemacht dass man in einer
haushaltspolitischen debatte über die
prioritäten der bundesregierung und der
ampel mehrheit sprechen muss und eine
der prioritäten ist die bekämpfung des
rechtsextremismus liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das ist der richtige ansatz
dieser neuen ampel mehrheit und dieser
bundesregierung es ist aber vor allen
dingen mehr als ein lippenbekenntnis es
muss verbunden sein mit konkreten
maßnahmen die sind schon viele
angesprochen worden ich will mich aber
hier auf einer beschränkten die mir
besonders am herzen liegt und das ist
die verteidigung und der schutz der
ehrenamtlich tätigen und der
kommunalpolitikerinnen und
kommunalpolitiker die bespuckt werden
die bepöbelt werden die an ihren privat
anschriften belagert werden das muss
aufhören sonst werden wir keine leute
mehr finden die sich ehrenamtlich für
unsere gesellschaft engagieren und es
ist gut und richtig dass wir gerade auch
in diesen bereich die sensibilität
unserer sicherheitsbehörden erhöhen wenn
wir über die prioritäten der
bundesregierung und der
bundestagsmehrheit sprechen dann geht es
auch um die verteidigung der
bürgerrechte und gerade im digitalen
raum und deswegen bin ich ihnen liebe
frau bundesministerin besonders dankbar
dass sie sich beim thema chep kontrolle
so klar an die seite des bundes
justizministers und des digital
ministers gestellt haben denn wir müssen
uns einmal klar machen was das bedeuten
würde denn anlasslos und flächendeckend
jede private kommunikation gescannt
würde diese pläne auf der ebene der
europäischen union während das ende
jeder vertrauliche kommunikation während
das ende der privatsphäre während das
ende der informationellen
selbstbestimmung deswegen ist es gut
dass die bundesrepublik vorschlag das
mist mitmachen wird obwohl es in münster
und es ist doch weltfremd und naiv zu
glauben dass dieses instrument nur für
kindesmissbrauchs bekämpfung eingesetzt
würde sie sind doch die ersten von der
union die beginnen werden den einsatz
dieses instruments für weitere
kriminalitätsformen zu fordern das geht
doch schon los und genau deswegen darf
man diese tür nicht aufmachen und ich
sage ihnen noch was das gleiche gilt das
gleiche gilt für die
vorratsdatenspeicherung
wir haben eine situation in deutschland
in der nach vielen vielen jahren der
verantwortung der union im bereich der
innenpolitik keine
vorratsdatenspeicherung stattfindet und
damit die daten auch nicht genutzt
werden können wissen sie woran das liegt
das liegt daran dass schwarze sheriffs
von der union immer und immer wieder mit
dem kopf vor die selbe wand laufen
nämlich europäische und deutsche
gerichte wir haben also keine
möglichkeit diese daten zu nutzen und
diese bundesräte diese ampel mehrheit
wird eine verantwortungsbewusste
möglichkeit einführen können sich darauf
verlassen daten zu nutzen die
bürgerrechte zu schützen und damit dazu
beizutragen dass ein ganz widerliches
verbrechen das widerlichste straftaten
bekämpft werden und das ist der
kindesmissbrauchs gibt glaube es eine
nachfrage von kollegen tun lassen würde
ich mich sehr freuen ja auch sehr gern
coole dass sie die nachfrage zu lassen
wir sind uns einig im kampf gegen
kindesmissbrauch wollen das auch so
effektiv wie möglich machen und sie
haben das gerade auch ausgeführt ist
sicherlich das urteil des vgh von ende
april kann zu einem irischen fall gerade
zum thema vorratsdatenspeicherung oder a
nochmals und arbeiten nun mehr explizit
auch ausnahmen zugelassen hat von dem
grundsätzlichen verbot oder der
begrenzung
insbesondere auch was das thema nutzung
registrierung und aus lesung von
ip-adressen anbelangt würde ich
sicherlich auch bekannt dass alle
experten die damit zu tun haben
insbesondere bka-präsidenten münch genau
diese möglichkeit fordert und zwar
mindestens rückwirkend auf sechs monate
die frau innenministerin hat gestern
ebenfalls die nutzung dieser ip adressen
richtigerweise und dankenswerter weise
gefordert meine frage einziehen die fdp
sind sie mit diesem vorschlag der
nutzung der ip adressen auch rückwirkend
bis zu sechs monaten einverstanden nein
damit sind wir nicht einverstanden
lieber kollege und ich will ihnen ganz
deutlich sagen was der unterschied
zwischen ihnen und uns ist der
unterschied ist dass sie
verfassungswidrige gesetze machen um
dann darauf warten und dann darauf
warten dass das bundesverfassungsgericht
oder der genau aufschreiben und
ausbuchstabiert was sie dürfen und was
sie nicht mehr dürfen um dann
anschließend um dann an schließend genau
das aus dem gerichtsurteil abzuschreiben
und ins gesetz zu schreiben so arbeiten
sie der unterschied ist dass die neue
ampel mehrheit und insbesondere die fdp
so arbeitet dass sie sich vorher
überlegt was sind eigentlich gerne hätte
und was eigentlich was bringen würde und
auch ein parlamentarisches
selbstbewusstsein oder ein
parlamentarisches selbstverständnis hat
dass der gesetzgeber hier im deutschen
bundestag sitzt und bei allem respekt
nicht in karlsruhe denn dort findet
anschließend eine kontrolle der gesetze
stadt und nicht vorher und deswegen wird
diese bundesregierung deswegen wird
diese bundestagsmehrheit mehr
möglichkeiten schaffen als sie über
jahre gelassen haben weil sie immer und
immer wieder den gleichen fehler gemacht
haben und ich bin sehr optimistisch dass
damit die zahl der täter die wir
dingfest machen die hier vor gericht
bringen werden steigen wird und darauf
können sie sich verlassen die bayer
kollege drogen meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren ich will gerne diese
gelegenheit aber auch nutzen um neben
dem thema bürgerrechte um neben dem
thema krisenbewältigung extremismus
bewältigung auch etwas anzusprechen was
im bereich der innenpolitik nicht unter
den tisch fallen darf und das sind
strukturelle reformen ich habe nämlich
das gefühl dass unser
bundesinnenministerium einen wirklich
guten job macht wenn es darum geht
operative fragen zu klären und mit dem
operativen tagesgeschäft klar zu kommen
das ist ja auch völlig klar wenn man
sich den bundeshaushalt anschaut im
bereich des innenministeriums dann ist
dieses haus besonders geprägt durch
operative tätigkeiten gerade im bereich
der bundespolizei aber die innenpolitik
sie braucht auch strukturelle reformen
wir werden über das thema digitale
verwaltung noch sprechen wir müssen über
das thema cyber abwehr sprechen und über
das thema zivilschutz und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir müssen vor
einigen sprechen über das thema der
zuwanderung in den arbeitsmarkt dieses
thema darf nicht immer wieder der krisen
rhetorik und der krisenbewältigung in
unserem land zum opfer fallen wir haben
es wegen kuroda nicht hingekriegt wir
haben's nicht hingekriegt weil die union
mit ihren lebenslügen in puncto
einwanderungsgesetz nicht klargekommen
wir haben jetzt das thema ukraine was
wir bewältigen müssen aber wie russland
ist auf die kette kriegen zu beginn
dieser legislaturperiode einen
paradigmenwechsel in der
einwanderungspolitik hinzubekommen mit
einem wettbewerbsfähigen
einwanderungsgesetz mit einem
punktesystem und auch mit einer
situation wo wir in den hunderten und
tausenden gesprächen die wir jeden tag
mit arbeitgebern führen die sagen mir
fehlen hier fachkräfte bringt sie uns
endlich sagen können wir haben es
geschafft und wir haben einfach noch
zusatz für deutschland auf den weg
gebracht diese strukturreform sie müssen
auch sein und die fdp macht gerne mit
vielen dank
kurz die coole stellvertretender
vorsitzender der fdp-fraktion hatte in
seiner rede noch mal auf einen die sense
hingewiesen
der basiert auf den plänen der
eu-kommission nämlich gibt pflicht die
geplante pflicht für google facebook und
andere ihre seiten nach missbrauchs-
fotos und videos zu durchsuchen das von
der sogenannten chat kontrolle die rede
und die ist nach wie vor umstritten
könnte auch in der koalition zu einer
deutlichen konflikten noch führend fritz
güntzler ist am pult ob man im
sportausschuss und das ganze für die
unionsfraktion habe ich im hause alle
einig hat eine besondere
gesellschaftliche bedeutung das betrifft
sowohl die nicht organisierten sport
aber auch den organisierten sport in
deutschland über 27 millionen menschen
treiben in fast 90.000 vereinen sport
dieses alles nur möglich weil es ein
großartiges ehrenamtliches engagement
von fast neun millionen menschen gibt
die weit über 500 millionen stunden
arbeitsleistung einbringen und ich finde
diese menschen können wir heute morgen
mal danken
der sport ist auch mehr als
gesundheitscoach er leite leistet einen
wichtigen beitrag zum gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt zur integration zur
inklusion zur demokratie förderung zur
bildungsarbeit aber insbesondere auch
bei der kinder- und jugendarbeit das
schafft verbindungen vermittelt wichtige
werte wie respekt teamgeist und fairplay
die wir auch teilweise hier alle walten
lassen sollten deshalb braucht der sport
unsere gemeinsame unterstützung und ich
weise darauf hin gerne darauf hin dass
wir in der großen koalition in der
letzten legislaturperiode der einiges
geleistet haben der sport etat ist von
162 millionen euro auf fast 500
millionen euro angewachsen darunter auch
200 millionen corona hilfen aber der
eine sportförderung aufwuchs sind über
70 prozent und ich finde da können wir
horst seehofer noch mal ganz herzlich
danken dass er das nach vorne gebracht
hat
und wir sind uns auch einig dass die
sportvereine besonders in der kroner
zeit gelitten haben sportveranstaltungen
waren nicht mehr möglich der
trainingsbetrieb musste teilweise
eingestellt werden die sportler haben
mitglieder verloren unterschiedlicher
art bei den kleinen vereins weniger als
bei den großen vereinen du musst es
richtig die bundesinnenministerium hat
ja darauf hingewiesen dass ist jetzt ein
projekt neustart nach corona geben
sollen ich finde es aber schon
bewundernswert in anführungsstrichen
dass es in dem entwurf der
bundesregierung dafür nichts enthalten
war sondern das was der
haushaltsausschuss war der 25 millionen
euro eingestellt hat der wird sich
ungefähr 270 euro pro verein da ist also
noch ein bisschen luft nach oben also
ich wir finden es grundsätzlich richtig
peinlich finde ich aber schon dass der
haushaltsausschuss das mit einem
sperrvermerk versehen muss weil derzeit
nach sieben monaten immer noch kein
konzept dieser bundesregierung vorliegt
und frau ministerin hier müssen sie auch
mal handeln
leider zieht sich das ein roter faden
auch durch die sportpolitik das was ich
vorhin auch schon zur sicherheitspolitik
hier hören durfte dass sie vieles
ankündigen aber nicht handeln sie
sprechen im koalitionsvertrag der
immerhin eine halbe seite für die sport
darüber hat von einem entwicklungsplan
sport der entwickelt werden muss
fehlanzeige auf unsere nachfrage
sportausschuss es gibt derzeit gar
nichts in diesem punkt der deos weder
deutsche olympische sportbund hat jetzt
vorschläge vorbereitet und vorgelegt
damit man überhaupt in die diskussion
kommen liebe frau feser bevor sie
personal entlassen sollen sie über man
inhalte gehen und über inhalte
nachdenken damit sie tatsächlich dinge
die sie im koalitionsvertrag vereinbart
haben auch umsetzen wir können auch
weitergehen zur mittelvergabe beim
spitzensport sie haben geschrieben in
den koalitionsvertrag sie wollen eine
unabhängige instanz schaffen zur
mittelvergabe kein mensch weiß derzeit
was diese instanz sein sollen der dfb
weiß es nicht die beteiligten wissen es
nicht wir haben eine förder kommission
derzeit vom bundesinnenministerium
gemeinsam mit dem dmsb die das gut macht
sie wollen die neue instanz schaffen
sagen aber gar nicht wie und wieder
zeigt sich sie handeln nicht sie
kündigen nur an kollege hat es
angesprochen auf den sieger ausbau die
sanierung von sportstätten und sie
schreiben im koalitionsvertrag nicht nur
für kommunale sportstätten sondern auf
der vereinseigenen sportstätten da kommt
jetzt gerade mal über bis zum jahr 2027
476 millionen aus da haben wir uns in
der großen koalition schon mehr gemacht
meine wir haben 600 millionen drittel in
einem jahr da geht mehr und für die
vereinseigenen sportanlagen haben sie
wieder keine lösung gefasst auch da wie
waren sie nicht also im ganzen
zusammengefasst es wäre noch mehr punkte
zu nennen wo sie nicht handeln nehmen
sie die aufgabe ernst nehmen sie den
sport ernst im menschen die eben dem
sport tätig sein haben es verdient dass
sie ernst genommen werden sie brauchen
wertschätzung und nicht nur
ankündigungen herzlichen dank
nächster redner für die spd-fraktion die
akquise der
krise ist einer der stellvertretenden
fraktionsvorsitzenden
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
kolleginnen und kollegen es gibt ja das
phänomen in debatten und reden dass man
sonntagsreden hält dass man lob das man
das ehrenamt lob das man applaus
bekommen möchte und das lieber fritz
münster das war nicht gut und ich hab
gerade auch geklatscht was ich mir noch
nicht ganz erklären kann und wir haben
wir die klare fokussierung auf den sport
ist wieso der kollege der kläger im
haushaltsausschuss 7 kürzungsanträge für
den sportbereich eingereicht hat das
passt aus meiner sicht nicht ganz
zusammen und da hätte man schon ehrlich
sein müssen die prioritätensetzung für
den sport war wohl bei der union ganz so
ausgeprägt ist wohl die kommunikation
zwischen raushauen sportpolitiker bei
ihnen an dem rundgangs waren in der
ampelkoalition setzen wir gemeinsam mit
bundesinnenministerium nancy faeser
einklagen schwerpunkt auf die innere
sicherheit weil wir als ampelkoalition
einen umfassenderen begriff von innerer
sicherheit haben innere sicherheit heißt
für uns nicht strafverschärfungen allein
im strafgesetzbuch sondern genau da
hinzuschauen und zu fragen wie können
wir kriminalität verhindern wie können
wir sicherheit vorbeugend erhöhen für
die bürgerinnen und bürgern in diesem
land und das ist der schwerpunkt den wir
in diesem haushalt setzen der sich im
haushalt wiederfinden und ist der größte
haushaltsetat im innenbereich den wir
jemals gehabt haben und da bin ich den
haushälterin und haushalt der
koalitionsfraktionen sehr dankbar in
westfalen würden wir sagen das habt ihr
ganz ordentlich gemacht vielen dank
dafür
es ist angesprochen worden die stärkung
des technischen hilfswerks setzen sich
fort die sind richtig und die
herausforderungen sind da das haben die
flutkatastrophe im aartal gezeigt dass
haben aber auch gerade erst die tornados
in paderborn und lippstadt gezeigt wie
wichtig es ist auch aufgrund der
klimatischen veränderungen hier
voranzugehen und ich bin der thw
helfervereinigung dem präsidium martin
gerster und andrea lindholz sehr dankbar
dass sie in einer pressemitteilung das
was die ampel koalition hier gemacht hat
ausdrücklich loben dass es gut fürs thw
und gut für die katastrophenhilfe bei
uns im land
ausdrücklich hervorheben will ich auch
die stärkung der bundespolizei ist es
angesprochen worden und wir wollen
darüber hinaus mit einer klaren
prioritätensetzung auch die
arbeitsbedingungen für die
bundespolizeibeamten und polizeibeamten
voranbringen durch einen bundespolizei
gesetzt was gerade bei den unterkünften
bei den liegenschaften für die
polizeibeamtinnen und -beamten richtige
weichenstellungen auf den weg bringen
wird aber sind wir ehrlich es gehört
genauso dazu die ruhegehalts fähigkeit
der polizei zulage auf den weg zu
bringen hier haben wir uns als
ampelkoalition zu entschlossen das
werden wir auch den weg bringen hier hat
das innenministerium früher blockiert
ich bin dankbar dass das jetzt nicht
mehr passiert dass wir das vor anregung
die gdp als die gewerkschaft der polizei
hat das aus wirklich auch noch mal
begrüßt und hier werden wir die
entsprechenden vorlagen auch sehr
zeitnah auf den weg bringen
ebenso sitzt das bundesinnenministerium
nennt sich nancy faeser entschuldigung
nancy faeser aber auch die klare und
richtige priorität auf die bekannte
bekämpfung des extremismus und gerade
die größte bedrohung die wir im land
haben die bekämpfung des
rechtsextremismus und ich sage es
nochmal zum ausgangspunkt dass wir
genauso oft prävention setzen oder darum
werden wir als ampel koalition gemeinsam
bundesinnenministerium
bundesfamilienministerium eine
demokratie fördergesetz auf den weg
bringen weil wir die demokratie in
unserem land stärken müssen damit die
demokratischen initiativen die sich
täglich überall dafür einsetzen
unterstützen wollen auskömmlich
finanzieren wollen die demokratie muss
wehrhaft sein dazu braucht sie die
unterstützung und das werden wir jetzt
ampelkoalition zeitnah auf den weg
bringen
ebenso werden wir auf den weg bringen
und das bin ich dankbar dass der kollege
coole das auch noch mal prioritär
angesprochen hat wir werden mit einigen
lebenslügen im bereich migration und
einwanderung aufräumen müssen wir sind
ein einwanderungsland wir brauchen ein
modernes einwanderungsrecht wir brauchen
ein chancen aufenthaltsrecht und den
menschen die lange hier sind die in
kettenduldungen gewesen sind die
perspektiven zu geben auch hier werden
wir vorankommen und dann zum schluss
vielleicht noch eine anmerkung
eine anmerkung an den an den kollegen
toben das neue stilmittel der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion zeichnet sich ja den
debatten dadurch aus dass man fragen
stellt das haben wir ja gestern auch
erlebt und sie sind da vielleicht ein
bisschen durcheinander gekommen mit den
staatssekretären wie das jetzt zukünftig
ausgesiedelt ist von daher das
instrument der klar in anfrage der
fragestellung ist vielleicht gut dass
bei ihnen da sehr schnell aufklärung
geben können über die zusammensetzung
der staatssekretäre da haben sie ein
bisschen was durcheinander gebracht in
diesem sinne vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
nächster redner für die afg fraktion
jürgen könig
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kollegen und vor allem liebe
sportler die regierung hat den sport
haushalt knapp fünf jahren fast
verdoppelt auf jetzt 3 138 millionen
euro die afg hatte schon 20 18 gefordert
bis zum jahr 2022 den sport mit jährlich
340 millionen euro zu fördern
herzlichen glückwunsch frau ministerin
herzlichen glückwunsch lieber
ampelkoalition sie haben unseren
vorschlag zu 99,4 prozent umgesetzt so
was wenn man eine punktlandung
frau ministerin sie waren haben 27 april
bei uns im sportausschuss viele ihrer
damals da gelegten vorhaben im sport
hätten auch von afg kommen können
beziehungsweise sind schon seit 2008
zehn in unseren sport politischen thesen
formuliert ein paar beispiele
sie nennen es integration des
vereinssports mit den schulen und
ganztagsschulen wir nennen es bessere
kooperation von schule und sportverein
und mein beide dasselbe die
talentsichtung und talentförderung durch
partnerschaften zwischen schulen und
sportvereinen auszubauen nächstes
beispiel wir wollen gemeinsam die
ausrichtung von sportgroßveranstaltungen
mit dem ziel dass in deutschland wieder
olympische spiele stattfinden die
special olympics 20 23 fußball leben
2024 universiade 2025 in deutschland
sind dafür meilensteine
winter 20 30 in münchen sollte das ziel
sein denn eigentlich war münchen schon
20 22 dran das wäre auch dreimal besser
gewesen als diese polit propaganda show
in peking die sportpolitik geht zurzeit
in die richtige richtung erhöhen sie
weiter den gesellschaftlichen
stellenwert des breiten wie auch des
spitzensports aber kollege wintzler hat
es angesprochen wir werden ganz genau
schauen ob und wie sie ihre vorhaben
auch wirklich umsetzen
hätten sie den einen oder anderen von
unseren sieben anträgen zum haushalt
aufgenommen irgendwie aufgenommen ja
dann wäre der sport haushalt in einer
einzelabstimmung eventuell sogar
zustimmungsfähig gewesen sport frei und
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
nächste rednerin für die fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen tina winklmeier
frau präsidentin frau ministerin
kolleginnen kollegen sportlerinnen und
sportler liebe ehrenamtliche haushalt
heißt nachverhandlungen und langen
nächten zahlen zu präsentieren und damit
unsere gesellschaft antworten zu geben
ich möchte jetzt nicht diese imposanten
zahlen einzeln präsentieren sondern eben
auch zeigen was wir damit tun da kommt
jetzt der sport ins spiel sport ist
emotion ist leidenschaft freude und
trauer und ist hingabe und viel folgt es
ist der spitzensport der idole
hervorbringt und diese idole bringen die
breite in bewegung da durchkommen
menschen nicht nur zum sport sondern der
sport bekommt eine tragende rolle für
das gesellschaftliche zusammenleben
sport vermittelt demokratische werte
für uns heißt sportpolitik sich aktiv
für gleichstellung einzusetzen inklusion
leben den kampf gegen rechtsextremismus
und rassismus aufzunehmen aufzunehmen
sport integriert auf allen ebenen sport
bringt uns zusammen er eint uns
unsere athletinnen athleten sind hier
vorbilder und brauchen unsere klare
unterstützung sie sind nicht nur im
inneren in ihren disziplinen weltklasse
sie sind auch starke persönlichkeiten
mit staaten stimmen treten rechte müssen
deshalb aktiv und unabhängig gestärkt
werden dafür müssen wir ihnen als
politik bestmögliche voraussetzungen
schaffen um mit diesem haushalt gehen
die einen großen schritt in die richtige
richtung
neben
neben den tisch der nächsten rein vor
ort und dem spitzensport inland haben
wir aber auch den blick auf die dienende
pandemie mit am meisten zurückstecken
mussten wir bringen kinder und
jugendliche nach coruna wieder in die
sporthalle und auf die sportplätze dafür
müssen die sie aber auch den standard
erfüllen dafür braucht es mittel und
diese stellen wir
halt
alle diese aufgaben tragen im sport vor
allem menschen im ehrenamt dafür gebührt
ihnen anerkennung denn die breite basis
im sport überhaupt nicht möglich ohne
all die freiwilligen die er die freizeit
opfern um menschen für bewegung und das
miteinander zu begeistern
sport muss aber auch angstfrei offen und
ein vorbild sein gegen jegliche art der
gewalt und diskriminierung
und hier ist in den letzten jahrzehnten
zu wenig passiert
sexualisierte gewalt im sport ist ein
immenses problem von der breite bis in
die spitze und das muss deutlich
angegangen werden und mit uns wird es
das auch
mit einem unabhängigen zentrum für
selbstmord schaffen wir eine instanz die
den kampf gegen gewalt im sport aufnimmt
und genauso sieht es beim thema doping
aus auch hier bedarf es noch sehr viel
mehr aufklärung und prävention
hand in hand für sauberen und ehrlichen
sport und das gehen wir an
das was sport ausmacht was sport was
spitzensport voranbringt hier gibt es
noch einiges zu tun um dieser aufgabe
haben wir uns leidenschaftlich
angenommen und mit einem klaren aufwuchs
der haushaltsmittel im sportbereich
fördern und fordern wir dass regierung
sehr gezielt damit unsere athletinnen
und athleten sich auf ihre leistung
konzentrieren können und wir mitfiebern
können damit sich die nächste generation
top athletinnen nicht nur als poster ins
kinderzimmer hängt sondern sich den
traum ab selber verwirklichen kann und
deswegen würde ich jetzt sagen so
schweißband an um papa sagen wir haben
was zu tun und wir ziehen das durch
dankeschön
nächster redner für die fdp-fraktion
doktor volker ridder
[Applaus]
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen sehr geehrte zuschauerinnen
zuschauer
wir können mit dem heutigen jetzigen
stand der verwaltungs digitalisierung
nicht zufrieden sein wir alle wissen von
den umsetzungsproblemen beim online
zugangs gesetz wir wissen dass in den
verwaltungen immer noch zuviel gefaxt
gedruckt und reihenweise in papier
ordnern abgeheftet wird wir wissen dass
da in den vergangenen jahren viel zu
wenig passiert wird er passiert ist
schuldig musste eben darüber gucken wir
steuern da jetzt um wie als ampel fang
mich mit diesem haushalt damit an
wir haben das zusammen mit dem
bundesfinanzminister geschafft die
haushaltsmittel für die verwaltungs
digitalisierung im vergleich zum vorjahr
um ein drittel also um eine halbe
milliarde 500 millionen euro zu erhöhen
das geld ist das eine aber insgesamt
muss natürlich die öffentliche hand
künftig auch proaktiver sein sie muss
als innovations- und gestaltung zu
treiben wirken bis in die wirtschaft
rhein war nur in diesem zusammenspiel
funktioniert das ganze
die öffentliche hand ist als größter
auftraggeber it-bereich verpflichtet
diese aufträge so zu vergeben das
staatliche förderung nicht mehr
notwendig sind man kann ja steuern über
diese aufträge und dabei ist durchaus zu
beachten dass diese vergabe lose den
mittelstand berücksichtigen wir haben
aktuelle situation dass die lose so groß
sind dass das nur noch großkonzerne
abarbeiten können und wir das natürlich
deutlich abhängig machen von diesem wir
haben hunderttausend personen tage lose
die ausgeschrieben werden welcher
mittelständlers was lief war aber der
mittelstand ist das rückgrat dieses
landes und der garant für den wohlstand
also da müssen wir ran wir müssen die
lose kleiner machen damit das
funktioniert damit wir auch nachhaltig
deutschlands wirtschaftsstandort stärken
ja es 500 millionen findet sich so
toller erfolg dazu gehört aber eben auch
die schnelle umsetzung innovativer
projekte an denen jede bürgerin jeder
bürger merkt warum wir als ampel des
fortschritts koalition sind wir setzen
auf die besten lösungen zur umsetzung
in meiner letzten rede hat die schon mal
das hatte ich schon etwas erklärt über
die förde titel object ein neues konzept
mit dem man daten bitte
das ist aber nett freundlich
[Gelächter]
also mit mit diesem pferd virtuelle
objekt zu
schaffen wir es schaffen wir es
tatsächlich eine eine prozess steigerung
von mindestens 30% konservativ gerechnet
es gibt experten die sagen 80 prozent
das heißt wir werden es in dieser
legislatur erleben das analoge amtswege
den meisten bürgerinnen und bürgern
erspart bleiben das ist ein versprechen
das kriegen wir hin
wir investieren als appell in einem
moderneren digitale rinnen
bürgerfreundlichen staaten schaffen
zugleich ein größeres maß an staatlicher
souveränität und wirtschaftlichen
wettbewerb bei gleichzeitiger
kostensenkung durch den einsatz von
neuen technologien dieser haushalt dass
der erste seit langem der und diese
moderne richtung geht dank an alle die
an diesem haushalt mitgearbeitet haben
heute ist ein guter tag für die
digitalisierung und für deutschland
vielen dank
volker rede als fdp fraktion in der
debatte über den einzelplan sächsinnen
und heimat plus einzelplan 21
bundesdatenschutzbeauftragter und dieser
debatte die drittletzte rednerin ist
mechthilde wittmann aus der
unionsfraktion spezielle csu
landesgruppe
legen mein vorredner hat geschlossen mit
dem hinweis heute wäre ein guter tag
durch diesen haushalt da kann ich ihnen
ausdrücklich zustimmen und ich sage
ihnen auch warum frau bundesminister den
phaser hat bei der letzten debatte zu
diesem thema mehr ausdrücklich
beigepflichtet dass es sich um einen
kontinuierlichen haushalt handelt einen
haushalt der kontinuierlich die
haushalte der vergangenen legislatur
fortsetzt und damit bestätigt die
bundesministerin wie auch dieser
haushalt in den wesentlichen punkten die
erfolgreiche innenpolitik die in den
letzten jahren hier geschrieben worden
ist insbesondere von der union aber auch
wenn sie ab und zu eine september
amnesie haben von der spd die sich so
gar nicht mehr erinnern will dass sie
mit uns regiert
meine damen und herren es bestätigt sich
auch ganz einfach in der
kriminalitätsstatistik wo wir
erfreulicherweise ganz große erfolge
seit jahren fortsetzen können und ich
zuversichtlich bin dass sich aufgrund
der hervorragenden arbeit unserer
sicherheitsbehörden
da habe ich heute noch nichts dazu
gehört bei den vielen dankesreden auch
es so weiter entwickeln wird wir haben
einen kontinuierlichen rückgang der
straftaten in fast allen bereichen
die aufklärungsquote steigt die
häufigkeit zahlen der straftaten sinkt
und auch die zahl der tatverdächtigen
sind kontinuierlich und dies obwohl wir
bei den nach verfolgungen viel
intelligenter sein können allerdings und
auch hier haben wir gemeinsamkeit
bewiesen wir möchten stocken den anstieg
der straftaten insbesondere im
rechtsextremistischen bereich ich glaube
hier sind wir uns im hause bis auf
einige sehr sehr wenige vollkommen einig
und diesen weg werden wir uns gemeinsam
gehen und jeder euro ist hier gut
investiert
aber wir haben auch einen anstieg bei
den betrugsdelikten und wir haben einen
anstieg bei den tätlichen angriffen auf
die vollstreckungsbeamte das sind die
die vor ort die sicherheit aller
bürgerinnen und bürger garantieren und
das dürfen wir ebenfalls nicht zulassen
dürfen wir nicht ignorieren
und schließlich und endlich wurde schon
ausführlich von meinem kollegen
ausgeführt zum zur frage des anstiegs
des exponentiellen anstieg bei der frage
der sexuellen missbrauchs von kindern
aber auch vorbei verbreitung erwerb
besitz und herstellung von operativen
pornografischer schriften insbesondere
kinderpornografischer schriften hier um
mehr als 100 prozent
das dürfen wir nicht so stehen lassen
und deswegen ist es mir vollkommen
unbegreiflich dass sie sich in der ampel
allen ernstes auf rückfrage von kollegen
leisten den dissenz was wir einsetzen
müssen damit wir hier eingreifen können
und dazu gehört der zugriff auf die
ip-adressen frau bundesministerin da
haben sie unsere unterstützung leider
nicht die von ihren kollegen mit denen
sicher arbeiten müssen aber dazu gehört
auch die vorratsdatenspeicherung und
hier geht halt einfach zu differenzieren
es geht um den anlassbezogenen
zugriff selbst wenn anlasslos
gespeichert werden konnte damit wir
aufklären können und nicht da stoppen
müssen wir uns die daten sähen um
endlich diese täter zu fassen wir wollen
den schutz der bürger und nicht der
kriminellen
und lassen sie nicht nach dem dies schon
auf meinen kollegen ausführlich
geschildert worden ist umfrage zur frage
des bevölkerungs und katastrophen und
zivilschutz ist hier nochmal einmal kurz
erläutern warum wir den ergänzungsantrag
aufrechterhalten richtig sie haben jetzt
zugelegt es ist gut so aber wir wissen
auch dass die mittel die sie uns
besondere für die mina bahn app die so
wichtig ist wie nie zuvor wie wir
erfahren haben nicht ausreichen werden
um sie ausreichend auszustatten nehmen
sie doch die gelder diese geparkt haben
stimmen sie dem antrag zu es tut nicht
weh und dafür können wir hier endlich
volle arbeit leisten das ist wichtig so
der kollege bohlen war noch das thema
personal schon angesprochen ich darf
noch mal kurz darauf eingehen jawohl wir
sind sehr glücklich dass wir ebenso
kontinuierlich weiter auf beim bei der
bundespolizei aber auch in den
entsprechenden ämtern das ist eine gute
fortsetzung der bisherigen politik und
jetzt dix an dieser stelle ich danke
unseren polizei an ordnungskräften
ebenso sowie der dank an alle an dann
gingen sie schließen wir uns an danke
ich den polizei und ordnungskräften die
jeden tag ihren kopf dafür hinhalten
wenn wir das bei uns funktioniert und
ich darf dazu auch gleich noch einmal
beim weitergehen und ihnen eines sagen
wir haben über rechtsextremismus
gesprochen dass wir uns da richtig
verstehen ja wohl das sind wir ganz an
ihrer seite ich habe kein wort zum thema
linksextremismus gehört es sind die
linksextremistischen gruppen die in
erster linie hier die gewaltbereitschaft
gegen unsere polizei in richtung gegen
die beamten vor ort die den dienst dort
verrichten und es ist mir nicht
begreiflich dass sie versuchen wir offen
können nicht die augen zuzumachen das
wollen wir nicht und erinnern sie sich
nur an den g20-gipfel in hamburg vom
heutigen bundeskanzler als
hafengeburtstag tituliert tatsächlich
aber unter anderem ein tag des
ungehorsams mit unfassbaren fast 1000
verletzten polizisten
das kann es ja wohl nicht sein im
übrigen haben sie mehr als zehn prozent
davon aus bayern gebraucht um diesen
gipfel überhaupt bewältigen zu können
und ihre gäste überhaupt in sicherheit
bringen zu können
an diesem tag war der tag des
ungehorsams ausgehoben und ich zitiere
ihre partei ihre kollegin ihre
kabinettskollegin städten lemke es ist
absolut legitim für seine anliegen zu
demonstrieren und aus dabei auf formen
des zivilen ungehorsams zu nutzen nein
das ist es nicht weit
das ist es nicht
und wenn sie coole von den schwarzen
schärfste union sprechen dann sage ich
ihnen mal ein assist hat schon ein grund
warum der bundeskanzler diesen g7-gipfel
nach ellmau verlegt hat weil kein
nämlich weiß nur dort sind seine gäste
so sicher wie sie es brauchen und wie
sie es bewiesen haben nur dort haben sie
best practice und deswegen sind wir
stolz darauf dass wir diese sicherheit
für die gäste in unserem land liefern
können stehen
mechthilde wittmann aus der
unionsfraktion mit einem rückblick auf
den g7 gibt für den hamburg dass es
jetzt auch schon ein paar jahre her und
bevor in dem einen und anderen md
bürgerbüro sorge entsteht auf der redner
anzahl in dieser debatte und unserer
übertragen keine panik ich habe mich
schlicht und einfach verzählt und wir
bleiben natürlich live drauf über viele
viele stunden noch nicht nur einer
kleinen unterbrechung im laufe des
späteren nachmittags also alles in
ordnung nur der kommentator hat sich
verzählt 43 rednerin kommen noch und ein
redner zum beispiel dunja kreise aus der
spd fraktion jetzt am pult ist
als ehemalige sportliche politische
sprecherin des landtages in
niedersachsen bin ich stolz in dieser
andere koalition jetzt im bundestag
mitwirken zu können die zeigt dass die
ehrenamtlichen in unserer gesellschaft
hier eine besondere beachtung erfahren
sie sind das rückgrat unserer
gesellschaft
wir können deshalb bis bank auf dem
beitrag meiner kollegin sabine poschmann
sein die zur sportstättenförderung zur
unterstützung der vereine nach bewohner
zu den großveranstaltungen die special
olympics zu dem programm integration im
sport verehrte damen und herren
berichten wird wir machen keinen großen
ausschlag zur unterstützung der
ehrenamtlichen und hauptamtlichen zivil
und katastrophenschutz zum beispiel aus
dem ergänzungs haushalt 50 millionen
plus für eine moderne ausstattung
riechen der ausgaben für die beschaffung
im zusammenhang mit den ausgaben durch
den krieg in der ukraine wir stehen das
waren meldesystem digital auf frau
widmann und das versteht einfach schon
drin natürlich redundant aber so dass
die endgerät mit der nina bahn netz
schnell die bevölkerung erreicht wird
mit dem modularen wahnsystem mouras und
der einführung der sms warnung für steak
fast 99 millionen in der ersten tranche
für einen neubau für den thw in einen
neubau programm für die gebäudetechnik
damit sind wir auf dem weg zu einem
resilienz zivil und katastrophenschutz
der bewaffnet ist für umweltkatastrophen
für internationalen krisen einzige lung
katastrophenschutz sehr vor allem aber
auch den blick auf die menschen hat
verehrte damen und herren 8 millionen
euro wie ein neues zentrum für die
einsatznachsorge
um eine bessere psychosoziale betreuung
zu gewährleisten ist dringend geboten
für die einsatzkräfte in
krisensituationen für unsere ehrenamtler
dazu kommt ein großes paket für
digitalisierung und cyber sicherheit der
kritischen infrastruktur für die
kompetenz erweiterung des thws für die
härtung der struktur innerhalb des
malteser hilfsdienstes entwicklung
digitaler lagebilder zur besseren
koordinierung zwischen land bund und
kommunen digitalisierung verehrte damen
und herren zeigt sich im übrigen in dem
gesamten haushalt neben vieler
verpasster aufgaben in den letzten 16
jahren ist wohl die digitalisierung in
unserer verwaltung im zivilschutz und
auf dem bildungssektor das was am
meisten verschlafen wurde wir wagen
fortschritt wir bringen die
digitalisierung der verwaltung voran
davon profitieren die ehrenamtlichen
davon profitieren alle bürgerinnen und
bürger davon profitieren unternehmen wir
haben so haben wir das so zb demo cd
booster auf den weg gebracht bis zum
ende des jahres werden wir deutliche
erleichterungen tag spüren 35 wichtige
verwaltungsdienstleistungen werden dann
digitalisiert sein es ist zeigt dass
deutschland endlich sein potenzial los
und eine moderne verwaltung anbietet die
die behörden und bürger in den
mittelpunkt stellt ehrenamt feder
verehrte damen und herren wird aber vor
allem in den bereichen mit dem haushalt
gestärkt wo wir durch politische bildung
medienkompetenz und prävention eine
wirksame bereicherung in unserem
gesellschaftlichen zusammenleben
erfahren werden für mehr toleranz
respekt demokratie und gegen rassismus
unsere gedanken sind heute bei den
angehörigen von weiter lücke
nun ja kaiser war das los der
spd-fraktion in der debatte über den
etat des bundesinnenministeriums in
dieser debatte jetzt matthias helferich
afd aber trotzdem fraktionslos
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren bereits der
philosoph alexy de tocqueville warnte
dass der demokratie stets die gefahr
innewohne sich in eine tyrannis der
mehrheit zu entwickeln er schreibt die
mehrheit zieht einen drohenden kreis um
das denken innerhalb dieser grenzen ist
man frei aber wer wenn man sie zu
überschreiten watt auch heute droht
unsere demokratie schaden zu nehmen sie
alle beschädigen unsere freiheit ordnung
wenn die opposition im parlament
ausgrenzen gar kriminalisieren eines
ihrer instrumente ist der
verfassungsschutz welcher mit rund 488
millionen euro ausgestattet wird zwölf
millionen euro erhalten die schlapphüte
im vergleich zum vorjahr mehr zwölf
millionen euro doch wofür eigentlich vor
dem tunesischen terror fahrer anis ambri
konnte der vsg unser volk nicht schützen
wohl aber scheint der vsg die regierung
eifrig vor der demokratischen opposition
zu schützen die opposition wird aber als
lästiger kontrolleur machtbewusst durch
sie alle durch das establishment
ausgegrenzt dem parlament
parlamentarischen kontrollgremium
welches die tätigkeit des
verfassungsschutz überwacht darf kein
afg ab da sitzen dem vertrauensgremium
des haushaltsausschusses was die mittel
zuwendung für den verfassungsschutz
überwacht darf ebenfalls kein afg
abgeordneten gehören unter wundern sie
sich ernsthaft noch dass die bürger
unseres landes das vertrauen in die
demokratie verlieren sie schalten den
willen des demos aus und bauen unsere
demokratie schamlos in eine parteien
herrschaft aus ein weiteres indiz dafür
ist während die stiftung des
establishments ich immer hemmungsloser
am steuer gelten für die afg nahe
stiftung keine mittel erhalten der grund
man wirft ihr fehlende verfassungstreue
vor und wer ist der ankläger ihr
instrumentalisiert verfassungsschutz der
nicht von der opposition kontrolliert
werden darf transparenz und
oppositionelle mitspracherechte sind für
sie lediglich makulatur die realität in
diesem hause ist brutale machtpolitik
ein hinweis sei mir erlaubt die 800.000
euro für ihre extremismus studie wären
sehr gut angelegt wenn sie als erstes
forschungsprojekt dem ober schlapphut
und verfassungsschutz präsidenten thomas
halbe wand wählen würden keiner betreibt
so leidenschaftlich wie er als
installierter behörden extrem ist die
jagd auf die demokratischen opposition
in unserem land vielen dank
[Applaus]
helferich für die bezeichnung gehörten
extremist erteile ich ihnen einen
ordnungsruf
da nimmt er noch einen ordnungsrufen mit
auf seinen platz in einer letzten reihe
und obwohl im moment der fraktion nicht
angehört aber doch der partei haben auch
noch einige applaudiert aus den reihen
der fraktion der fdp wir sind jetzt
tatsächlich bei der vorletzten rednerin
angekommen marlene schönberger bündnis
90 die grünen
sprechen wir wieder über die realität
wann haben wir das letzte mal jüdische
eltern gefragt wie fühlt es sich
eigentlich an eure kinder an der polizei
vorbei zur jüdischen kita zu bringen und
ihnen die sicherheitsmaßnahme zu
erklären warum haben wir uns daran
gewöhnt dass juden juden hinter
stahlbeton mauern und kugelsicherem glas
beten müssen wann haben wir die blutspur
antisemitischer gewalt akzeptiert wie
sie ronen steinke in seinem buch terror
gegen juden beschreibt wie können wir es
zulassen dass antisemitismus alltag ist
liebe kolleginnen
es reicht nicht sich auf ritualisierten
nie wieder auszuruhen es ist unsere
gemeinsame pflicht die erfahrungen
jüdischer menschen in deutschland zu
hören und unser handeln weiter daran
auszurichten so wie wir es im
koalitionsvertrag beschlossen haben und
beginnen jetzt im ersten haushalts
umzusetzen
wir stärken den absolutismus
beauftragten bestärken jüdischen
initiativen den rücken für ihren einsatz
für eine demokratische gesellschaft für
vielfalt und gegen verschwörungs
ideologien und die förderung jüdischen
lebens das bedeutet für uns auch dass
wir das drängende problem der
altersarmut von jüdinnen und juden
endlich angehen wir legen mit dem
härtefall- vor den grundstein dafür
liebe kolleginnen für die nächsten
haushaltsjahre liegen wichtige aufgaben
vor uns antisemitische gewalt und nicht
nur von rechts von islamisten sowie
teilen der politischen linken
antisemitismus ist bis in die
vermeintliche mitte der gesellschaft
hinein alltag der schutz jüdischer
einrichtungen eine beschämende
notwendigkeit dabei kann es nicht sein
dass es jüdische gemeinde selbst für den
schutz vor antisemitischen angriffen
aufkommen müssen die sicherheit
jüdischen lebens ist eine
gemeinschaftsaufgabe
[Applaus]
typisch reden defizite defizite die
leben kosten können das werden wir in
absprache mit den jüdischen gemeinden
angehen und genauso werden wir die
ursache den antisemitismus bekämpfen mit
prävention intervention und repression
das heißt mit politischer bildung und
monitoring mit polizei und
sicherheitsbehörden die antisemitismus
auch erkennen und mit gerichten die ihn
auch konsequente bahn
kollegen ich will dass es vor jüdischen
kindergärten schulen keine polizei mehr
stehen muss ich will dass würden juden
keine neuen anschläge fürchten müssen
ich will dass wir etwas tun gegen
antisemitismus bei demonstrationen auf
unseren schulhöfen am arbeitsplatz und
im internet ich will dass wir jeden
antisemitismus immer und überall
bekämpfen und ich weiß dass das alle
demokratischen fraktionen wollen
dieser haushalt leistet einen wichtigen
beitrag dazu vielen dank
marlene schöneberger aus der fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen noch mal auch mit
einem appell aber auch mit einer
forderung an die bundesregierung
jüdische mitbewohnerinnen und
mitbewohnern mehr zu schützen und die
letzte redner in der debatte jetzt aber
sabine poschmann die sportpolitische
sprecherin der spd fraktion
denn ohne breitensport keinen
spitzensport als
top athletin wird man nicht geboren
sondern man wächst hinein und entwickelt
sich
in meiner heimatstadt dortmund erlebe
ich durch die olympiastützpunkte und
natürlich durch die vielen engagierten
vereine die hervorragende arbeit
geleistet wird gerade in der pandemie
sehr kreativ da ist es gut meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren dass wir als
zuständige für den spitzensport auf den
breitensport unter die arme greifen
16 millionen menschen in deutschland
sind mitglied in einem sportverein
welche positiven auswirkungen sport auf
die gesundheit den geist das miteinander
hat brauche ich hier nicht zu erläutern
aber deshalb ist es wichtig und richtig
dass wir erstens gerade jetzt ein
restart für den sport hingekommen und
finanziell ausstatten dabei steht für
mich die qualifizierung und
weiterbildung von übungsleitern im fokus
aber
auch den menschen den zugang zum sport
wieder zu erleichtern
zweitens ist es wichtig dass wir bei der
sanierung von sportstätten eine
ordentliche schippe drauflegen und
dabei
und das ist auch wieder jetzt der
wechsel und dabei nachhaltigkeit eine
wichtige rolle spielt
vor allem sollten die athletinnen und
athleten immer im vordergrund stehen
deshalb freut es mich dass wir neben
deutschland zusätzlich finanziell
ausstatten und den grundstein für ein
zentrum safe spot legen
für diese ergebnisse danke ich den
haushalt
und haushältern der koalition
insbesondere martin gerster und hrubesch
mit
um jetzt
voran zu kommen
was sechs jahre teilweise in einem cdu
ministerium nicht passiert ist zum
beispiel bei der spitzensport reform
muss jetzt endlich eine passende
umsetzung erfolgen lassen sie uns mal
damen und herren in bewegung bleiben und
gemeinsam mit den verbänden aber auch
mit den athletinnen und athleten
gestalten das ist das schlüsselwort
herzlichen dank
sabine poschmann nochmal zum thema sport
das ja auch in den bereich der
bundesinnenminister regen fällt und ganz
nebenbei sabine poschmann leitet
zusammen mit dirk wiese den bvb fanclub
bundestags borussen hier im bundestag
und jetzt gibt einiges abzustimmen zum
beispiel zwei änderungsanträge hören wir
rein was vize-präsidentin aydan özoguz
aufruft
stimmen wer stimmt für den
änderungsantrag der fraktion der cdu/csu
auf drucksache 20 48 da geht es unter
anderem um das notfall informations und
die notfall information und nachrichten
app nina und andere informationstechnik
im bereich zum des katastrophenschutzes
ein änderungsantrag abgelehnt wer stimmt
für den änderungsantrag der fraktion der
afg auf drucksache 20 49 das ist die afg
fraktion und dabei wird es mutmaßlich
auch bleiben und es geht um die
gesamtsumme der förderung politischer
stiftungen übrigens und um den antrag
der fw fraktion die db rios erasmus
stiftung in diese förderung mit
aufzunehmen gesehen auch das ist
abgelehnt worden jetzt die abstimmung
zum einzelplan 06 des bundesministerium
des innern und für heimat das ist cdu
csu fdp und die linke enthaltung keine
dann ist der einzelplan 06 angenommen
wir kommen nun zur abstimmung über den
einzelplan
21 bundesbeauftragter für den
datenschutz und die informationsfreiheit
in der ausschuss fassung wer stimmt
dafür
das ist linke spd und 90 die grünen fdp
cdu csu wer stimmt dagegen
niemand wer enthält sich die afg
fraktion damit ist der einzelplan 21
angenommen